GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME BACK TO
SUBCOMMITTEE FORESTED
ADMINISTRATION. WHO ROLL CALL TO
SUBSEQUENTLY?
COOPER HERE. BRO CABALLERO HERE
CHIU CHOI HERE.
WITH SIXTEEN ON THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR TRAVEL MOTION ITEMS ONE.
THREE THREE NINE.
11-3 TWELVE FOURTEEN AND SIXTEEN
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
OF ALL IN MOTION.
ALSO GONNA.
WELL. IT'LL BE YOU NUMBER ONE
THREE THREE NINE.
ELEVEN AND TWELVE
FOURTEEN AND SIX.
REPUBLICS.
COOPER I BROKEN ARROW BY.
CHIU CHOI AYE.
TRAVEL MOTIONAL ITEMS TEN
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN.
AS M. L. SECOND AT A LOCAL
POLICE.
COOPER I.
GROW CABALLERO BY.
CHOI HIGH.
UNLESS MEAN AT LEAST LEVEL
MOTION ON ITEM NUMBER TWO.
THEIR MOTION.
AND ALSO GONNA.
LOCAL POLICE COOPER AYE
CABALLERO.
CHOI.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO OUT OF ORDER
AND START WITH.
.
ISSUE NUMBER NINE.
MISTER DALY.
MR ONE.
MRS APARTMENT FINANCE.
BUDGET IF THAT'S THEIR THING
CAO.
AND MISTER REALLY THE
PROTAGONIST ITEM ALONG WITH.
SOMEONE IRWIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS
PROPOSAL WILL CREATE A NEW MORE
FLEXIBLE STATE SAVINGS ACCOUNT.
TO WHETHER THE STATE'S BOOM AND
BUST REVENUE CYCLE IN INSULATOR
STATES RESIDENTS FROM CUTS MADE
DURING RECESSIONS.
THE BUDGET DEFICIT SAVINGS
ACCOUNT WILL BE AN ACCOUNT IS
COMPLEMENTARY.
STATES EXISTING RAINY DAY FUND.
FOUR YEARS AGO IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN VOTERS OVERWHELMINGLY
APPROVED PROPOSITION TWO A
MEASURE WHICH STRENGTHEN THE
STATE'S EXISTING BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT.
BY INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT THE STATE CAN SAVE.
WHEN THE ECONOMY AND REVENUES
ARE HEALTHY.
I JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED FULLY FUNDING
THE BUDGET STABILIZATION ACCOUNT
TO ITS CONSTITUTIONAL CAP OF
THIRTEEN POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS.
COURSE WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S GOAL TO SAY WELL
TIMES ARE GOOD.
HOWEVER AS THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S RECENTLY POINTED OUT
FILLING THE BUDGET STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT TO ITS CONSTITUTIONAL
CAPACITY.
COUNTER INTUITIVELY MAKES
PREPARING FOR RECESSION MORE
DIFFICULT IN FUTURE YEARS.
EVEN WHEN FULLY FUNDED THE
BUDGET STABILIZATION ACCOUNT IS
LITTLE MORE THAN HALF OF WHAT
CALIFORNIA WOULD NEED.
TO INDOOR A MILD RECESSION.
THE LTO BELIEVES THE STATE WILL
ACTUALLY NEED TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN SAVINGS TO BATTLE A
MILD RECESSION OR FORTY BILLION
IN SAVINGS TO BATTLE A MODERATE
RECESSION.
ESTABLISHING AN ADDITIONAL
RESERVE IS A LONG TERM REFORM
THAT WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
FUTURE GENERATIONS ARE NOT
SADDLED WITH OUR DEBT OR FORCED
TO MAKE SEVERE CUTS. TO
EDUCATION AND OTHER IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS.
WITH ME TODAY ARE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS IRWIN AND GRAYSON.
WHO WERE AMONG THE NINE JOINT
AUTHORS OF THE BILL WHICH WE
INTRODUCED LAST MONTH TO
STIMULATE THIS DISCUSSION?
THANK YOU SIR ONE AND LET THE
RECORD REFLECT THAT MISTER
BROTHERS JOINED US.
I'M A PLEASED TO BE HERE WITH A
THREE OF OUR JOINT AUTHORS TO
TALK ABOUT AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
THIS BILL REFLECTS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT RESPONSIBILITIES
OF THAT LEGISLATURE ENSURING
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS ADEQUATE
RESERVES TO PROTECT CRITICAL
SERVICES DURING RECESSIONS.
CALIFORNIA'S REVENUES FLUCTUATE
IN RESPONSE TO CHANGES IN THE
ECONOMY. AND STOCK MARKET MUCH
MORE THAN OTHER STATES LEADING
TO DOWNTURNS THAT ARE REFERRED
TO AS BUDGET PROBLEMS.
BUDGET PROBLEMS AT THE STATE
LEVEL MEAN REAL LOSSES TO OUR
CHILDREN'S EDUCATION AND
HEALTHCARE AMONG OTHER THINGS.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY CREATES A
PATHWAY TO PROTECTING
CALIFORNIANS IN LESS PROSPEROUS
TIMES.
GRAYSON.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THIS MEASURE PROPOSES A SIMPLE
MECHANISM TO SAVE BEYOND THE
RAINY DAY FUND WHILE WE CONTINUE
TO ENJOY BUDGET SURPLUSES.
NOBODY IN THE LEGISLATURE WANTS
TO BE IN THE SITUATION WHERE WE
ARE CHOOSING BETWEEN ESSENTIAL
SERVICES. LIKE EDUCATION
HEALTHCARE SUPPORT FOR SENIORS
AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
YET CUTS ARE COMING AND EVEN
WITH THE RAINY DAY FUND IT IS
NOT GOING TO BE ENOUGH TO FULLY
INSULATE US FROM OUR REOCCURRING
BOOM AND BUST CYCLES.
AS MY COLLEAGUE HAS ALREADY
POINTED OUT AND COLLEAGUES BOTH
THE LA ILL RECENTLY SAID THAT WE
WILL NEED AT LEAST TWENTY
BILLION TO PREP DEL PROTECT. US
AGAINST A MILD RECESSION YET THE
THIRTEEN POINT FIVE BILLION
PROPOSED WE WILL STILL HAVE A
LONG WAY TO GO. AFTER YEARS OF
HISTORIC GROWTH WE ALL KNOW
REVENUES WILL DROP AGAIN IT'S AN
ABSOLUTE CERTAINTY
WITH THIS BILL WE SIMPLY ASK
THAT YOU HELP OUR CONSTITUENTS
OUR FUTURE LEGISLATORS. BY DOING
A FIST OF FISCAL FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE THING. AND THAT'S
PUTTING MORE BACK AND WE THINK
THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS EFFORTS IS.
LL.
FINANCE.
NEITHER HART.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NOT WHILE
THE ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZE THE
INTENT OF THIS LANGUAGE TO BUILD
A MORE ROBUST RESERVE TO ADDRESS
FUTURE RECESSION NEEDS WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. AS IT
APPEARS TO CIRCUMVENT THE
VOTER'S INTENT TO SPEND THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS ABOVE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT MAXIMUM
ONE IF STRUCTURE PROGRAMS.
BUT YOU. ANY FROM THE COMMITTEE
DOCTOR CHOI.
YEAH SURE HER THEN EMAIL OPPOSE
HIS SET AND THAT WE DO HAVE A
MECHANISM.
TWO YOU WOULD LAST A EXISTING
SPECIAL FUND UP FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY AYE ACCOUNT DON'T.
WHY IS IT NECESSARY IT DOESN'T
CREATE THAT ANY ANY ERA? A BUT
FANTASIA FOR HAVING JUST PERCENT
OF TALENT THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION.
THE ADDITIONAL ACCOUNT WILL
GIVE.
THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
MORE FLEXIBILITY.
IN FUTURE YEARS.
ESPECIALLY IF REVENUES CONTINUE
TO.
THE RECEIVE AT THE LEVELS THEY
ARE ARE NOW OCCURRING.
.
THE LA SHOW DID A VERY NICE
ANALYSIS.
WHICH IN LAYMAN'S TERMS SAYS
THAT THAT THAT.
A FALSE CHOICE HAS BEEN CREATED.
IF THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
WANT TO PUT MORE MONEY IN
RESERVE UNDER THE CURRENT
STRUCTURE.
WE CANNOT THIS WILL ALLOW US TO
HAVE AN ADDITIONAL RESERVE.
SO WHAT WHAT WAS THE.
REQUIREMENT THAT WHY IT CAN'T
THE WHAT I UNDERSTAND IS THAT
THE AT THE SUDDEN PUSH NHL.
EXCEEDS OUT THAT THE SPURS
HANDLE CAO TO RAINY DAY. AND
THEN THE US SALES TAX I HAS TO
BE UP. OF REDUCED OR IS THAT A
NICE THING NAM TO REFUND AND
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE. SADDEST
TAXA ó TO OUR TAXPAYERS WITH
THE GOAL HERE IS TO IS
CREATE THE.
POSSIBILITY OF AN ADDITIONAL
RESERVE.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT THERE IS
NOTHING IN THIS PROPOSAL THAT
REQUIRES THAT ADDITIONAL RESERVE.
TO BE.
.
SOME OF THE BUDGET MONIES BE
ALLOCATED TO IT BUT IT DOES GIVE
UP THE PROVIDE THE FLEXIBILITY.
THE OPTION.
CHOICE
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
SHOULD WE.
OF THE DECIDE TO PURSUE IT. AYE
I GET SOME IDEA TO RIGHT NOW WE
CANCER RIGHT NOW IF WE WANT TO
PUT MORE MONEY IN RESERVES WE
CANNOT.
A I I GUESS.
MY SIMPER INTERPRETATION OR BE
OUT. WHEN.
WE HAVE OUR ACCESS AS SUCH
SURPLUS A SURPLUS OF NASA NICE
TO SAY THAT UNLESS UP WITH THAT
THE MONEY ASIDE DOES NOT FOR
WHAT RAINY DAY A.
AND WE CAN USE THAT THE BUT THE
WHEN. ARE. WE CONTINUE TO HAVE A
SURPLUS IS OUT AND ATTACKED ME
AND. OUT WE ARE ASSESSING
EXCESSIVE TAX TO OUR CITIZENS
PIE. SO AT THE SUDDEN ARE PUT A
THRUSH OR JUST OVER THEN WE
SHOULD STOP THAT AND THE MAYBE
OF REDUCED US YOU KNOW TAX.
WHAT WAS CITIZENS US SO FAR SAID
WE HAVE COLLECTED THAT THE MONEY
OUT ESCAPE IT? AND A CONTINUE TO
TAX MORE.
REGARDLESS SO FAR. YET EXIST
AMOUNT.
THAT THE REVENUE AND A SOAP SO
PRODUCES SURPLUSES TO WE
GENERATE.
I THINK THERE IS THIS IS
ALLOWING THAT TO STE POLICY
DISCUSSION OF WHAT ACTUALLY A OF
REASONABLE AND RESPONSIBLE
RESERVE IS.
THE BUDGET WAS CLOSE TO TWO
HUNDRED.
BILLION DOLLARS AND THIS IS
LESS THAN TEN PERCENT OF THAT.
SO IT ALLOWS THE FLEXIBILITY OF.
THAT THAT POLICY DISCUSSION TO
SAVE TEN PERCENT TO TO SOME OF
THE CITIES THINK THAT FIFTEEN
PERCENT IS RESPONSIBLE.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE STUCK AT THE
LEVEL THAT.
WAS. PROP TO PASS.
OKAY AT EL LA OR MAYBE I YOU CAN
EXPLAIN NOT.
WHEN WE HAVE A TWO HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLAR YOU KNOW. IT IS
AT THE TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS UP
TO ONE TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS
SEXIST SO WHAT AMOUNT IS OUR
IDEA. OF WHAT THE KIND OF.
RECESSION ARE WE ANTICIPATING
IT FOR.
A RECESSION HIT SO WELL WHAT
WILL CUT ABOVE BUDGET THAT ARE
WE ANTICIPATING THAT'S THE SHORT
THAT WE. NEED THIS EXTRA FUND.
ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT WE HAVE A
SO FAR OF CUMULATED.
I ANALYSTS ALEJO.
WE DID ANALYSIS RECENTLY WHERE
WE LOOKED AT YOU KNOW DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF RESERVES THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED.
IF LEGISLATURE WANTED TO
WHETHER DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
RECESSIONS.
SO YOU KNOW THE SHORT ANSWER TO
THE QUESTION IS THERE'S NO RIGHT
LEVEL OF PREPARATION THERE'S NO
SORT OF MAGIC NUMBER IT DEPENDS.
A LOT ON.
THE LEGISLATURE'S ASSESSMENT OF
HOW BIG THE NEXT RECESSION WOULD
BE. AND HOW MUCH THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD BE WILLING TO MAKE
PROGRAMMATIC CUTS ARE REYES PA
REVENUES DURING A RECESSION
VERSES I WANTING TO RELY SIMPLY
ON RESERVES BUT WHAT WE FOUND.
IS THAT.
TO WHETHER A MILD RECESSION THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD MEAN ABOUT
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS FROM
MODERATE RECESSION IT WOULD NEED
ABOUT FORTY BILLION DOLLARS.
AND FOR A MORE SEVERE RECESSION
LIKE THE ONE IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT IT WOULD NEED MUCH MORE
THAN FORTY.
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE
TO FOLLOW UP ON DOCTOR CHOICE
QUESTION BECAUSE.
WE'VE GOT TO RESERVE ACCOUNTS
NOW WE GOT THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT AND YOU
ARE CORRECT WE CANNOT PUT MORE
THAN TEN PERCENT OF STATE
REVENUES IN THAT ACCOUNT AND
THAT WE ARE PROPOSING TO FULLY
FUND AT THIS YEAR.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE A SPECIAL FUND
FOR ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY WHICH
DOES NOT HAVE A CAP ON IT SO THE
QUESTION IS WHY I AND I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE NEED TO HAVE MORE
RESERVES AND I THINK WE DO NEED
TO HAVE MORE RESEARCH I THINK
IT'S. VERY CLEAR BUT I QUESTION
WHETHER OR NOT YOU NEED TO HAVE
A THIRD TYPE OF ACCOUNT BECAUSE
THE US AT THE U. DOES NOT HAVE A.
A CAP SO WHY NOT JUST PUT THE
MONEY IN THE US HAVE YOU.
AND THAT'S NOT HOW HOW I READ.
THAT'S THE SUBJECT.
AS LAID OUT BY THE LA YOU KNOW
MAYBE THE LA O. CAN HELP US WITH
THAT QUESTION.
AND YET SO THERE'S.
AS YOU SAID THERE IS TO.
TO RESERVE THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT OF A
SPECIAL FUND FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTIES THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT HAS A
LIMIT OF ABOUT TEN PERCENT OF
GENERAL FUND REVENUES. THE SFU
DOES NOT HAVE A LIMIT AT HIGHS.
TO STATUTORY SALES TAX TRIGGERS.
THAT WOULD REDUCE THE BALANCE
OUT OF THE AS IF YOU BY ABOUT%
ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
IF EITHER OF THEM ARE TRIGGERED.
THEY WOULD BE TRIGGERED IN THE
CASE OF THE ON EITHER THE
RESERVE REACHING ON ABOUT FOUR
PERCENT OF GENERAL FUND REVENUES
OVER THE COURSE OF TWO FISCAL
YEARS OR THREE PERCENT OF
GENERAL FUND REVENUES.
AS WELL AS A DETERMINATION BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT.
THE BUDGET.
ESSENTIALLY THAT RESERVES HAD
GROWN UP BETWEEN MAY AND
SEPTEMBER SO I WAS FAMILIAR WITH
THOSE PROVISIONS SO IF I CAN
RESTATE. I'D.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CREATING A
THIRD TYPE OF RESERVE ACCOUNT SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO CUT THE
SALES TAX RATE BY A QUARTER
PERCENTAGE IS THAT FAIR.
I WOULD SAY IT GIVES THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR CHOICES.
IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
ANTICIPATE THAT IT SIMPLY GIVES
THE WHAT GIVES US FLEXIBILITY
AND GIVES US CHOICES.
OKAY I MEAN I JUST.
I WOULD DARE TO RESIDENTS A
FALSE CHOICE THE CURRENT SYSTEM
THAT. CREATES A SERIES A FALSE
CHOICES.
I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE MORE
ALRIGHT REFER ENOUGH YOU YOU
KNOW I I I THINK WE ARE UNIFIED
IN OUR DESIRE TO SAVE MORE MONEY
BECAUSE WE ALL AGREE WITH THE LA
THOUGH THAT A TEN PERCENT
RESERVE IS NOT ENOUGH.
HOWEVER.
WHEN THE SFU WAS CREATED THIS
STATUTORY SALES TAX CUT WAS I
PUT HIM BECAUSE. OUT OF
RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THAT.
IF WE HAVE A IN A HEALTHY
RESERVE THEN MAYBE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE TAXED A
LITTLE LESS.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S ON
A REASONABLE CHOICE AND THE
ENABLING. LANGUAGE IN THE SMB
YOU SAYS THAT IF THE RESERVE
ACCOUNT BALANCE WHEREVER TO DROP
BELOW. A FOUR PERCENT OF THEM
THE OUGHT THIS QUARTER CENT
SALES TAX WOULD AUTOMATICALLY BE
REINSTATED. SO THAT TO ME THAT
SEEMS LIKE A REALLY REASONABLE
PROPOSITION AND I WOULD HAVE A
HARD TIME
EXPLAINING TO MY CONSTITUENTS
WHY THEY DON'T DESERVE TO PAY A
LITTLE BIT LESS IN TAX USELESS.
NEXT YEAR BECAUSE WE'RE TAKING
AND SO MUCH REVENUES THAT'S
THAT'S MY CONCERN WITH WHAT'S
BEING PROPOSED HERE.
HILL AYE I THINK KIDDO.
BY AGREE WITH THE SPIRIT OF
YOUR STATEMENT I THINK
CHOICES ARE.
A SHOULD BE BROADER AND MORE
VARIED THAN.
DAN.
AS YOU LAID THEM OUT I ALSO
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT I DO HAVE
A CO AUTHORS I SAID I AND IT'S
ACTUALLY WE.
THE WHO SUPPORT THIS.
ALRIGHT WELL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ANSWER THE QUESTION.
MR BROKE.
IF WE WERE MOTION ALL SECOND
THAT.
OR THINK YOU OFFER TO BRING
THIS FORWARD NUMBER ONE
ONSLAUGHT OF MATTER.
WELL HEATHER IF WHILE THE DESERT
SESSIONS MATTER WHEN YOU KNOW
FROM LAST TIME. NUMBER PROGRAMS
NEVER FULLY FUNDED TO THEIR
EXTENT PARTLY RECESSIONS I
THINK'S IMPORTANT IS TIMELY. AND
IT HELPS YOU CAN NEVER HAVE
ENOUGH IN A RAINY DAY FUND.
ONLY GOOD OPEN TO PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU WISH TO SPEAK ON
THIS ITEM.
CAL CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE CHAIRS ARE CONDITIONAL THIS
IS TO ADOPT POLLS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR THE MOTION CLEAN OF
LOCAL POLICE.
COOPER I BROKE.
CABALLERO. CHIU.
CHOI.
MOST BETH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THINK
.
TERRACE ARE WITH ISSUE NUMBER
ONE AS A CANVAS REGULATION
IMPLEMENTATION ENFORCEMENT. A
RESTORED MEMBERS TESTIMONY FIRST.
BUT THE DOCTOR WOODS HERE.
MORE PEOPLE.
WE COULD HAVE IT WITH A VERY
LONG AGENDA.
SO HOW ABOUT YOU COME UP AND.
THEY'LL GO GET HIM AGAIN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR THANK YOU FOR
PATIENTS ARE SIR.
.
START BY THANKING MISTER LACKEY
WAS IN HERE BUT I WAS GONNA
FOLLOW HIS TESTIMONY.
SO REGARDING THE CANNABIS A
ENFORCEMENT FUNDING AS YOU KNOW
THIS IS AN INDUSTRY IS CRITICAL
TO THE ECONOMY OF MY DISTRICT.
THE COMPREHENSIVE STATE A SET OF
LAWS AND REGULATIONS THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION THE VOTERS HAVE
CREATED FOR THIS INDUSTRY. FOR
THE PAST FOUR YEARS TO DESIGN TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC'S HEALTH AND
SAFETY AS WELL AS UPHOLD STRONG
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS WE ARE
PROUD OF IN THE STATE.
BUT THIS IS SIMPLY WITH WE HAVE
CREATED IS ALSO EXCEPTIONAL
EXPENSIVE AND DIFFICULT FOR
BUSINESS OWNERS TRYING TO ENTER
THE MARKET TO NAVIGATE.
WHO WANT BUSINESSES TO COMPLY WE
HAVE TO MAKE IT FAIR AND
REASONABLE? BUT NOW THE HIGH
COST OF COMPLIANCE AND
RELATIVELY LITTLE ENFORCEMENT
ACTION AGAINST UNCOMMITTED
BUSINESSES IS MAKING IS CREATING
A PERVERSE INCENTIVE TO STAY OUT
OF THE REGULATED MARKET WHICH OF
COURSE IS NOT WE HOPE OR
INTENDED.
WE DON'T CHANGE THAT DYNAMIC WE
WILL NEVER HAVE THE HEALTHY
REGULATED INDUSTRY THE VOTERS
CHOSE TO CREATE.
CONTINUE TO COME UP WITH
WOEFULLY SHORT A WILL COME UP
WOEFULLY SHORT IN THE TAX
REVENUE THE VOTERS WERE PROMISED.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT LOCKING PEOPLE
UP FOR TAKING DOWN THE A OR OR
TAKING DOWN THE COURT CARTELS AS
MR LACKEY WILL SAY. THIS PROGRAM
WAS CREATED BY PROP SIXTY FOUR
BUT WON'T BE FUNDED DUE TO A
LACK OF.
TO LACKLUSTER TAX REVENUE THIS
YEAR.
THE DOLLARS FOCUS OF THE OF
FOCUSED ON SUPPORTING
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE CREATED
A PATHWAY TO COMPLIANCE WITH A
CANDIDATE CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
NEED HELP ENSURING THAT BAD
ACTORS ARE NOT SUCCESSFULLY AND
UNDERCUTTING LICENSE BUSINESSES
WITHOUT CONSEQUENCE.
THERE MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
LICENSE CANNABIS FARMS IN HUMBLE
COUNTY BUT THE SHERIFF IN MY
DISTRICT ESTIMATES ARE THIRTEEN
THOUSAND AND PERMITTED GROWS IN
HUMBLE COUNTY ALONE.
HE ONLY HAS FIVE DEPUTIES TO
ENFORCE THE LAW.
WITHOUT HELP LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
WILL CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE TO
ELIMINATE UNLICENSED BUSINESSES
THE PUBLIC WILL NOT BE PROTECTED
THE UNREGULATED PARK MARKET WILL
FLOURISH AND LICENSE BUSINESSES
WILL SUFFER.
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR.
MAYBE OPTIMISTIC TODAY THANK YOU
DOCTOR WOODS
.
SURE APPLICANTS MISTER CHIU UPON
THE YEAR.
VOTE ONLY KELLER.
THE BULLY CALENDAR.
WE'LL CATCH UP VOTE ONLY.
THANK YOU DOCTOR
.
SO WE HAVE.
SO BE ISSUES.
ONE THREE THREE NINE.
ON A LEVEL ALMOST A.
SO.
.
AND ONE THREE THREE NINE ELEVEN
TO TWELVE FOURTEEN THROUGH
SIXTEEN.
REPUBLICS
SHE.
ISSUES TEN THIRTEEN OF FIFTEEN.
CHIU BY.
FROM THEN LEFT NOT LEAST ITEMS
TO A NINE.
OUR JOBS ARE TO.
CHIP TO.
THE VOTE.
THAT UNDERLYING FROM MEDIA.
RELIGION TO.
CALENDAR.
SOME OF PROJECT.
MISTER CHAIR YOU NEED A MOTION
ON THIS.
SHE.
OKAY WHAT WE'VE MISSED LACKEY
MORE WHENEVER REST DEPARTMENTS
COME UP
.
CLINT COUNT APARTMENT FINANCE
I'M I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND DO.
AN OVERVIEW OF.
THE CANDIDATES HAVE PACKAGE
THERE'S MANY DEPARTMENT
REPRESENTATIVES IN THE AUDIENCE
TODAY.
SO AFTER THE PRESENTATION IF
YOU HAVE MORE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
I HAVE THEM JOIN ME AT THE TABLE
TO ADDRESS THOSE THANK YOU. AND
SO NAY REVISION INCLUDES A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS I RELATED IT TO CANNABIS
RELATED PROPOSALS.
THERE'S TWO MAIN FUNDING SOURCES
THE CANNABIS CONTROL FIND WHICH
RECEIVES ITS REVENUES THROUGH A
REGULATORY FEES AND THE CANNABIS
TAX FUND WHICH RECEIVES MONEY
THROUGH AN EXCISE AND
CULTIVATION TAX ON CANNABIS.
TOTAL EXPENDITURES FROM THE
CONTROL FINER EXPECTED TO BE
HUNDRED FORTY SIX MILLION AND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND SIXTY
SEVEN MILLION FROM THE CANNABIS
TAX FUND.
GIVEN THAT WERE IN THE EARLY
IMPLEMENTATION STAGES OF PROP
SIXTY FOUR.
ALL THE NON STATUTORY LEE.
SPECIFY DOLLAR AMOUNTS WERE
PROPOSING TO FUND ON A TWO YEAR
LIMIT TERM ASIS SO WE CAN COME
BACK IN THE FUTURE WITH MORE
INFORMATION. AND JUSTIFY ONGOING
RESOURCES FOR THESE ACTIVITIES.
AND NOW TO GET INTO THE REVENUES
HERE.
THINK WE ESTIMATED THAT CAMPUS
TAX REVENUE TO BE HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
AND SIX HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION.
AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THOSE ESTIMATES WERE COMPLETED
BEFORE WE HAD OUR FIRST TIME.
ACTUAL TAX PAYMENT WHICH IS
ABOUT THIRTY FOUR MILLION AT THE
END OF APRIL AND THAT NUMBER ON
THE SURFACE SUGGESTS THAT TAX
REVENUES WILL COMMENCE LATELY. A
SLOWER THAN ANTICIPATED.
AND ARE CANNABIS CONTROL FUND
REVENUES ARE ESTIMATED AT ABOUT
A HUNDRED NINETY MILLION IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
HOWEVER WE ARE CONCERNED IN THE
EARLY STAGES OF THE FISCAL YEAR
THAT THERE MIGHT NOT BE CASH
AVAILABLE SO WE'RE PROPOSING A
FIFTY NINE MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND LOAN. THAT WILL BE
REPAID IN NINETEEN TWENTY FROM
THE CANNABIS TAX ON.
AND TO DATE WE HAVE ACTUALLY
ISSUED A HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND LOANS TO
FUND CANNABIS ACTIVITY THAT'S
TAKEN PLACE WHILE REVENUES
HAVEN'T BEEN AVAILABLE. THAT IS
EXPECTED TO BE REPAID IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FROM THE
CANNABIS TAX ON.
NOW THAT GIVEN KIND OF A HIGHER
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE
EXPENDITURES AND.
.
REVENUES ARE GET INTO SOME MORE
DETAILS ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT'S.
SO THE THREE MAIN LICENSING
ENTITIES THAT EUROPE CANNABIS
CONTROL CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE IN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC MEN OF PUBLIC
HEALTH.
THEIR PROPOSALS MAINLY INCLUDE
RESOURCES RELATED TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF S. B. NINETY
FOUR. THAT INCLUDES RESOURCES
FOR LOCAL LIAISON USE IT UNITS
TO HELP WITH THE LOCAL
AUTHORIZATION PROCESS.
VARYING LEVELS OF RESOURCES
RELATED TO THE NORTH COAST
OFFICE THAT'S REQUIRED TO BE
ESTABLISHED IN STATUTE. AND I'M
VARIOUS A DOLLAR AMOUNT BETWEEN
THE ENTITIES RELATED TO THEIR
COLLABORATION ON ENFORCING AND
COMPLETING APPLICATIONS ON MICRO
BUSINESSES.
AND.
SOME UNIQUE COMPONENTS OF THEIR
PROPOSALS THAT BE YOUR OF
CANNABIS CONTROL INCLUDES ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FOR
QUALITY ASSURNCE.
MONITORING TEAMS ARE ORIGINALLY
CONTEMPLATED IN SP NINETY FOUR.
AND ONE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN. THAT AND HAS TWO FULL
APPROACH FIRST TO EXPLAIN TO
THOSE NOT IN THE REGULATED
MARKET THE BENEFITS OF BEING IN
IT. AND SECOND TO EXPLAIN TO
CONSUMERS THE BENEFIT OF PERSIAN
SING CANNABIS THROUGH THE
REGULATED MARKET.
THE PART OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE'S BUDGET INCLUDES
OUR PROPOSAL INCLUDES ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS HER
DEVELOPMENT IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE APPELLATIONS INCOMPATIBLE
ORGANICS PER.
PROGRAM THAT WAS INCLUDED IN S.
B. NINETY FOUR AND TWO POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS REALLY TO
SEE QUITE RELATED WORKLOAD IN
THE APPLICATION PROCESS AND
FIELD WORK.
THERE SIX POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CAT TAXI
AGENCIES MAINLY RELATED TO CASH
COLLECTION OF TAXES THAT
INCLUDES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT. OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION AND.
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT AND FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD.
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR
SECRETARY OF STATE RELATED TO
CANNABIS AND BUSINESS FILINGS
AND TRADEMARK WORKLOAD THAT'S
INCREASE IN JANUARY.
THERE'S ALSO ABOUT TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS SPREAD ACROSS
THEM THREE MAIN LICENSING
ENTITIES TO PAY OF THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS ON FOR
APPEALS OF LICENSE DENIALS
ENFORCEMENT ACTION AND
DISCIPLINE CASES.
THERE'S ALSO ABOUT ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION FOR THE CANNABIS
CONTROLS APPEALS APPEALS PANEL I
RELATED TO THEIR TWO NEW MEMBERS
THAT WERE PROVIDED THAT'S BEEN
NINETY FOUR SOME ADMINISTRATIVE
STAFF. AND THEN ATTORNEY
POSITION.
THERE'S THAT THE SECOND
COMPONENT IS SORT OF PRIORITY TO
PROGRAMS THAT WERE CALLING ON
THEIR STATUTORILY SPECIFIED IN
AT HIGH PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR
TO BE PAID. A TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR GOBIZ TO TO PROVIDE
A GRANT PROGRAM TO LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. AND AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS OUR PROVIDE
LEGAL SERVICES JOB ASSISTANCE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER TREATMENT. AND FOR
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
PRIOR DRUG CRIMES.
TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CENTER ON A MEDICINAL CANNABIS
RESEARCH TO FURTHER THAT I'M.
INTENT AREA THE INTENT OF THAT
CENTER. AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS
TO UNIVERSITY OUR UNIVERSITIES
TO BE CHOSEN BY THE BUREAU OF
CANVAS CONTROL. TO RESEARCH THE
EFFECTS OF PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR AND REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR.
AND THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
CHP TO DEVELOP AND ADOPT.
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE.
.
PROTOCOLS RELATED TO CANNABIS AS
WE DISCUSSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND REITERATED MAY
REVISION AND. DUE TO HOW
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR WERE
STRUCTURED IN THE FUNDING
COMPONENT OF THE PRIORITY THREE
PROGRAMS WON'T RECEIVE FUNDING
INTO NINETEEN TWENTY.
I WANT OTHER COMPONENT AS WE
HAVE TRAILER BILL RAILING WHICH
I RELATED TO THE FBI BACKGROUND
CHECKS. FOR CDF A IN CDP H..
SPRITE THE MILLIONS HERE WE
BROUGHT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AT
THE END OF FEBRUARY EARLY MARCH
TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
WHERE THE FBI DOESN'T THINK WE
HAVE. A SUFFICIENT STATUTORY
AUTHORIZATION FOR THEM TO
RECEIVE THAT INFORMATION. WE'VE
ACTUALLY.
HAVE THAT HAVE DIRECT FEEDBACK
FROM THE FBI NOW AND WE'RE
PROPOSING TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES
IN THE HOPES THAT THEY'LL.
AUTHORIZED THE DEPARTMENTS
RECEIVING THAT INFORMATION BY
THE END OF THE CALENDAR YEAR IN
THE END TERM WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE FORWARD TO TO BE OF THE
ISSUE ANYA LICENSES WITH THE
ACTUAL.
.
CAN IN TURN PROCESS WHERE WE
ONLY DO CALIFORNIA ONLY
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
THAT INFORMATION WILL THEN ONCE
WE HAVE THE FEDERAL BACKGROUND
CHECKS WILL BE RUN FINGERPRINTS
TO CHECK ON THOSE LICENSEES.
SO.
I THAT CONCLUDES THAT MY
COMMENTS TODAY THANK YOU OKAY
I'M A PAUSE AND THINK TESTIMONY
FROM US MOVEMENT LACKEY.
THANK YOU CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS I APPRECIATE THE
CHANCE TO SPEAK TO THIS ISSUE.
CENTRO LEGAL BUT DON'T USE
SALES BEGAN IN JANUARY. IT'S
BECOME QUITE APPARENT THAT
UNLICENSED CANNABIS ACTIVITY IS
A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM AROUND THE
STATE.
AS LONG AS I'M LICENSE ACTIVITY
IS ALLOWED TO PROMOTE
PROLIFERATE. IT WILL UNDERCUT
THE LEGAL MARKET THE PROP SIXTY
FOUR SET UP.
IN ORDER TO COMBAT THIS
CALIFORNIA MUST PROVIDE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES AGAINST
ILLICIT MARKET UTILIZING LOCAL
PARTNERS.
PROP SIXTY FOUR STAB WISH.
AN ARCHITECTURE FOR CANNABIS TAX
REVENUE TO FUND GRANTS TO LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS RELATED
TO THE IMPLEMENTATION OF LEGAL
CANNABIS.
HOWEVER THIS FUNDING IS NOT
CURRENTLY ANTICIPATED INTEL
TWENTY NINETEEN OR TWENTY TWENTY.
IN LIGHT OF THE THE TIME
SENSITIVE NEED TO SUPPRESS THE
ILLICIT MARKET. IT'S REQUESTED
THAT THE STATE PROVIDE RESOURCES
FOR THAT EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET TO FUND THESE GRANTS.
I REQUEST IS FOR TWENTY FIVE
MILLION IN GRANTS ADMINISTERED
BY THE BOARD.
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
WITH THE REQUIRED TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT MATCH FROM THE LOCAL
FUNDS.
TO CONDUCT OF FORSMAN AGAINST
ILLEGAL OPERATORS.
THIS WILL BE RESTRICTED TO
JURISDICTIONS THAT LICENSE
RETAIL CULTIVATION A SPECIFIED
PROP SIXTY FOUR.
THESE GRANTS WOULD SERVICE SEED
MONEY FOR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAMS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO ASSESS FINES AND
PENALTIES FROM LICENSE ACTIVITY
BUT COLLECTING THE MONEY FROM
THESE TAKES TIME.
THESE GRANTS WOULD ALLOW LOCALS
TO GET THEIR ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM
SET UP WITH THE GOAL OF. USING
COLLECTED FINES AND PENALTIES TO
FUND FUTURE ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
BUDGET STAFF FOR A LOT OF THEIR
HARD WORK.
AND.
YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS REQUEST
I AM SO I ACTUALLY HAVE ONE
RELEVANT COMMENT IN RELATION TO.
THAT EFFORT NOT FROM MY
PRESENTATION AS WE ARE.
PROPOSING FOURTEEN MILLION FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
ESTABLISH FOR INVESTIGATIVE
TEAMS THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
ONE INTERDICTION TEAM. WILL BE
FOCUSED ON MORE COMPLEX CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATIONS AS IT RELATES TO
FINANCIAL AND TAX EVASION
INVESTIGATIONS AND CRIMINAL CRAP.
AND I'VE COUPLE QUESTIONS CAN
EXPLAIN WHY DEAL LEFT SIDE TO
FLYNN DOJ ENFORCEMENT OF A PROP
FIFTY FOUR MONEY.
SO AND.
I THINK AS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY POINTED
OUT THERE DEFTLY WAS RECENT.
RESOURCES CONTEMPLATED IN THE
INITIATIVE FOR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
HOWEVER THOSE WON'T BECOME
AVAILABLE TILL NINETEEN TWENTY.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
DECLARATIONS AND FINING IN THE
INTENT THERE'S A LOT NO WAY AS
IT RELATES TO GETTING RATTLED
RID OF CRIMINAL ORGANIZATIONS
PREVENTING ILLEGAL DIVERSION TO
OTHER STATES. AND YET THERE WAS
NO RESOURCES REALLY DEDICATED TO
THOSE SOPHISTICATED CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATIONS SO WE THOUGHT IT
WAS REASONABLE TO FIND AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE RESOURCES
FROM THE CANNABIS TAX FUND.
SATYAJIT COMPONENTS OF THEIR FOR
TASK FORCES.
HOW DO YOU HOW THEY INTERACT
WITH LOCAL THAT'S PLAYED IN THE
BIG ISSUE WITH IN THE PAST?
DOJ AND WHEN THEIR TASK FORCES
WHETHER IT'S METHAMPHETAMINE
TASSELS FORCES MARIJUANA TASK
FORCES.
DOJ'S WE SUPPLEMENT THE SMALLER
COUNTIES BEER COUNTIES HAD THEIR
OWN ADDICTION TEAM SO HOW'S IT
GOING OVER TO THE LOCAL LEVEL
FOR GOING AFTER THE HIGH LEVEL
FOLKS.
WELL SO WE ACTUALLY IN OUR
TRAILER BILL SO.
STATUTORILY REQUIRED THAT THE.
INTERACT WITH LOCAL.
WITH.
LAW ENFORCEMENT STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING LOCALS AND I DON'T
HAVE THE SPECIFICS ON EXACTLY
HOW THOSE.
IN INTERACTIONS WILL TAKE PLACE
BUT I THINK IT WOULD BE A
BENEFICIAL RACE RELATIONSHIP
WHERE THERE PROVIDING LEADS FROM
THE STATE LEVEL AND THE LOCALS
TO THEM SO THAT THEY CAN.
IDENTIFY THE APPROPRIATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY TO AND TAKE
ACTION AND I DON'T KNOW IF
ANYBODY IN DEPARTMENT JUSTICE IS
HERE TO SPEAK MORE ELOQUENTLY TO
THAT BACK AND FORTH MULLIN
TALKING MOST LOCALS THEY HAVE.
FORCED FORCES IMPLICITLY THE
FUNDING TO HELP WITH THEM THEY
HAVE THE EXPERTISE THERE THEY'VE
BEEN DOING IT FOR SUCH QUITE
SOMETIME.
IF YOU. HEAD BEING HE'S BEEN
GONE EXTINCT FOR. LIKE WHAT
EIGHT YEARS NOW REGULAR CAME IN
OFFICE STILL HAS BEEN NOTE DOJ
KNOWN BUCOLIC ENFORCEMENT SO.
IT ALWAYS TO STAND THEM UP IN
TIME EGGMAN HIRED DIRECTS
HIRINGS GONNA TAKE SOME TIME SO.
WHAT'S IT WITH YOU MISTER
SLICKER ON THAT.
I THINK BECAUSE OF THOSE REASONS
WE THOUGHT THEY ARE THE
APPROPRIATE ENTITY LONG TERM TO
SORT OF INVESTIGATE AND ENFORCE
IN THIS AREA THAT'S THE REASON
FOR. CHOOSING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE UNDERSTANDING THAT ANY
RESOURCES THAT WE TO ESTABLISH
AT THE STATE LEVEL WE'RE GONNA
HAVE SOME RAIN BUT TIME TO BE
READY TO ENFORCE THE LAW.
I THINK YOU'RE SORT OF
COMPARING THAT TO THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT MAYBE ART
HAVE RESOURCES IN PLACE. BUT.
AGAIN BECAUSE THE INITIATIVE
ALREADY CONTEMPLATED FUNDING FOR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT. READ IT
WELL IN A CIRCUMVENT THAT.
SO.
CHAIRMAN HAD THIS IS CHRIS RYAN
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE THROUGH
LISTENING TO THE COMMENTS AND WE
UNDERSTAND IT QUESTIONS.
AND.
IT SIMILAR TO THE STRUCTURE
THAT YOU DESCRIBE BEFORE HIM
EARLIER YEARS.
WE HAD APPROACHED ME SEVEN ONE
MILLION DOLLARS AND.
IN RESOURCES AVAILABLE. TO WORK
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT BUT IS
THAT FINANCE DESCRIBED.
WE ARE GONNA BE REESTABLISHING
FOUR TEAMS.
AND REDEPLOYING THOSE RESOURCES
AND TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES.
COVERED IN THIS PROPOSITION BUT
WHAT MY CONCERN IS RIGHT NOW YOU
CAN DO THAT GAMING. YOU'RE
BEHIND THAT TWO THOUSAND
INVESTIGATIONS IN GAMING SO I
GUESS MY CONCERN IS.
IF YOU GUYS CAN'T.
KEEP UP WITH THE GAMING THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY IS WHEN THEY'RE FOR
GAMING HOW DO YOU PLAN ON
KEEPING UP. WITH THE CANNABIS
ISSUE.
SO. GREAT QUESTION AND AND AND
WE ARE HIRING A TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES IN THE GAMING WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE INDUSTRY.
TO ADDRESS THOSE GAMBLING
ISSUES.
WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT THE
WORKLOAD AND MARK A CLOSER LOOK
AT THE WORKLOAD AND ADDRESSING
THE ISSUES HAS ARE COMING OUT SO
BILLS COMMITTEE THIS IN MY
FOURTH YEAR IN ASSEMBLY NOW. IN
THAT.
WORKLOAD IS STILL BEEN THERE THE
ENTIRE TIME SO I HAVE A LOT OF
CONFERENCE THAT DOJ'S GONNA BE
ABLE TO. TRANSLATE THAT INTO THE
SAME WITH BEING THE ONE WHO
ACTUALLY STANDING SOMEBODY IT
WAS A BIG ISSUE RIGHT NOW. AND
IN OF LOCALS HAVE SOME CONCERNS
TO.
WILL THE MONEY TRICKLE DOWN AND
AND WILL THE EFFECT BE WITH THAT
SO.
THE IN JUST IN TIME FROM THE
LITTLE BIT LEERY ON THAT POINT.
AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
CONCERNED.
AND AND YOU MENTIONED THAT THIS
IS A AN ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING FOR SOMETIME.
I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION IS TAKING A NEW
LOOK AT THIS AND FOCUSING ON THE
THE ISSUES THATYOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT WITH THE INDUSTRY. ANNA A
CONCERTED EFFORT IS BEING PUT
FORWARD TO DEPLOY THOSE
RESOURCES SOUND ELSE IN THE
PLAYOFFS TUNING UP THOSE TASK
FORCES.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
CANNABIS TASK FORCES YES SO AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN WILL GO INTO.
HIRING AGENTS.
AND ADDRESSING THE ISSUES AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN BASED UPON
WITH RECRUITMENT RETENTION THE
DOJ WE ARE AS THAT MANY STATE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT STATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES HAVE BUT
YES AT DOJ WE HAVE STILL HAD
SOME PROBLEMS ITH RECRUITING.
MARTIN I LOVE COMES DOWN TO PAY
THE PAY OBVIOUSLY THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION. THE PAVE MUCH MORE
LUCRATIVE THAN THE STATE. SAW
THAT. IS GONNA CONTINUE TO BE A
PROBLEM BUT. I'M NOT GONNA.
BUT BEFORE THAT TO DESK CHAIR
WITH A POINT OF CLARIFICATION I
THINK YOU SAID THAT THE.
PAY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL OR STATE
LEVEL AT THAT THAT THE LOCAL
LEVELS RIGHT THE LOCAL LEVEL
SEEMS TO BE BETTER FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PAY ABSOLUTELY WE
HAVE AN ISSUE AT THE STATE
RECRUITING FOR STATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
LET'S THEY WHAT NOT AS DOJ RIGHT
CARRILLO HERE.
THANK YOU.
LL.
HOW INCREASING AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SO
IN GENERAL WE THINK THAT THE
PROPOSAL'S THIS YEAR DO YOU
APPEAR REASONABLE AND BASED ON
OUR PRELIMINARY REVIEW? AYE WE
DEFINE THEIR SUBSTANTIAL
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THE LEVEL OF
RESOURCES THAT WILL BE NEEDED ON
AN ONGOING BASIS IN LARGE PART
BECAUSE THIS IS SUCH A NEW
PROGRAM THERE IS A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT
WE'RE GONNA NEED. AYE SO WE
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMING FORWARD
WITH A PROPOSAL THAT'S FOR
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS WE THINK
THAT.
IS VERY HELPFUL BECAUSE IN TWO
YEARS WHEN THOSE.
START EXPIRING.
WE THE LEGISLATURE WILL BE ABLE
TO REVISIT THE ONGOING FUNDING
LEVELS AND MAKE SURE THAT I
THEIR PROGRAM THE BENEFIT OF
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
SO I THINK THAT'S A. VERY
VALUABLE THING I THINK THEY'RE
JUST A COUPLE THINGS I WANTED TO
FLY QUICKLY FOR YOU.
ONE IS A THE APPROPRIATE USES
OF PROP SIXTY FOUR DOLLARS I
KNOW THERE'S.
REFERENCE IN THAT AGENDA AYE TO
THAT ISSUE YOU WITH REGARD TO
DOJ.
THE ISSUE WE'VE JUST BEEN
DISCUSSING COMPROMISED FIGHT
ANOTHER SMALLER ISSUE.
WHICH IS RELATED TO THE AT TO A
PIECE OF THREE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT PROPOSAL
WHICH WOULD FIND WORKFORCE
RELATED ACTIVITIES CITIES ARE
THINGS LIKE. I'M HOPING
BUSINESSES TO.
HIGHER FROM CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
AND ALSO HELPING JOB SEEKERS TO
TO FIND JOBS WITHIN THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY. ARMS IT WASN'T CLEAR
OUT TO US IF THAT'S ELIGIBLE
UNDER THE PROP SIXTY FOUR WHICH
LIMITS THOSE.
EDT FUNDS TO APPLYING IN
ENFORCING STATE LABOR LAWS SO WE
JUST WANTED TO FIGHT THAT IS AN
ISSUE THAT COULD BE. FOLLOWED UP
ON I'M AND THEN THE SECOND ISSUE
WHEN IT'S A FIGHT FOR THE
COMMITTEE IS RELATED TO THAT
DEPARTMENT ATTACKS IN FEET
MINISTRATION.
SO WE DO THINK IT'S REASONABLE
FOR THEM TO GET ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR A VARIETY OF
ACTIVITIES THAT.
THAT THEY WILL BE UNDERTAKING
I'M THERE'S ONE PIECE THAT WE.
WE WANTED TO KIND OF FLAG AND
THAT PEACE IS RELATED TO THE
NUMBER OF TAXPAYERS I'M SO THE
TRAILER BILL FROM LAST YEAR
DRAMATICALLY REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF TAX PAYERS THAT DON'T HAVE TO
HANDLE.
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THAT IT.
HAS DISTRIBUTORS DOING TAX
COLLECTIONS OF TICKET FROM BELOW
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF OF ENTITIES
PAYING THESE TAXES TO PROVIDE
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED.
SO THERE WAS A SOME AYE SOME
WHATEVER REDUCTION THAT'S
REFLECTED IN THEIR MEN THEIR
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL A HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND WE THINK THAT
PROBABLY A ABOUT AN ADDITIONAL
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND REDUCTION
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE THERE.
THERE IT'S A GIVEN THAT
AUGMENTATION IT WOULD JUST BE OF
A TWO POINT ONE MILLION RATHER
THAN TWO POINT FIVE MILLION. SO
THAT WAS THE SECOND ISSUE IS
WANTED TO FIGHT FOR FOLKS.
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS IF IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE.
GO ON UP PUBLIC COMMENT WAS ITEM
YOU WISH TO SPEAK.
SURE MEMBERS RAN MARTIN
REPRESENT KHALIFA OUT OF SAN
JOSE AND BLACK WERE LOGISTICS
BOTH OF WHICH ARE. A.
COMPLIANT LICENSED.
PROVIDERS OF THE SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA I'M WE SUPPORT THE
FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
DOJ I'M APPROPRIATION AS WELL AS
THE INCREASED APPROPRIATIONS FOR
THE THREE REGULATORY BODIES.
DESPITE THE THOUGH BUT THE.
REPORTS EARLY ON THIS YEAR THAT
IT'S GONNA BE A VERY ROBUST
INDUSTRY IT HAS NOT TURNED OUT
TO BE NEARLY AS ROBUST AS WE HAD
HOPED. AND WE ATTRIBUTE A LARGE
PART OF THAT TO THE FACT THAT
THERE IS STILL A VERY HEALTHY
ILLEGAL MARKET OUT THERE. AND WE
HAVE STEPPED UP WE ARE COMPLIANT
WE ARE LICENSED AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO OPERATE OUR
BUSINESS.
ALONG WITH THE OTHERS WHO ARE
LICENSED I'M AND HOPE THAT WE
CAN GET THE ILLEGAL MARKET OUT
OF THE BUSINESS SO WE HAVE IT A
BIT ABILITY TO TO GROW AND
PROSPER AND HEALTH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON FRIEND MURPHY
WITH WE MAPS.
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY I THINK THAT
RESTRICTING THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION TO JUST AREAS THAT OUR
LICENSING IS A GREAT IDEA.
AND WHILE WE ALL KNOW THAT THE
ILLEGAL MARKET IS IS A MASSIVE
PROBLEM THE REALITY IS THE LEGAL
MARKETS DONE IT IS THERE FOR TWO
REASONS ONE THERE IS NOT ENOUGH
LOCAL LICENSES.
TO POSSIBLY DECREASE AT POINT.
EXCUSE ME ONLY EIGHTY PERCENT
EIGHTY PERCENT OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE NOT LICENSING
RETAIL.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE LEGAL ACCESS.
CAN ELIMINATE THE LEGAL MARKET
WON'T HAPPEN.
HOWEVER STEPS IN.
TAKING CRACK STEPS
DO ENFORCEMENT AND HELP
ENFORCEMENT IN AREAS THAT ARE
LICENSING RETAIL IS A GREAT IDEA
THANK YOU A QUESTION FOR YOU
THOUGH USAGE LIMIT TO THE AREAS
THAT OUR LICENSING.
WELL HERE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
FOR INSTANCE
NO WAY JURISDICTION HAS LICENSE
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO AS WE
KNOW SACRAMENTO.
PROPER IS NUMBER ONE FOR.
.
BLACK MARKET LABS ARE SEIZURES
OF CLANDESTINE AYE MARIJUANA
GROWS CAMPUS GROWS INTO NUMBER
ONE AND MOST OF THOSE ARE
INCURRING. OUTSIDE OF THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO SWISHING THEY'LL
GROW OVER A HUNDRED HOMES.
NO PASSED TWO YEARS SO.
NEWMAN HAS BEEN MONEY LOGISTICS
THAT LICENSE MEANWHILE. NEVER
JERSEYS THAT DON'T LICENSE.
THE USER IF GOD REPETITIONS WITH
GROW SO ATTY CORRELATE THE TOO.
HOT SUIT THE.
THE GENERAL NEXUS IN STATES THAT
HAVE LEGALIZED IS THAT THERE'S
THERE'S ESSENTIALLY TWO TWO WAYS
TO ELIMINATE THE BLACK MARKET TO
DECREASE IT.
ONE IS THROUGH RETAIL ACCESS AND
THE OTHER ONE AS A HEAVY
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM IN
CONJUNCTION WITH RETAIL ACCESS.
SO YOU HAVE TO EASE THE ANSWER
TO THAT I THINK IS HOPEFULLY
YOUR INCENTIVIZING ELK GROVE TO
DO LEGITIMATE.
WORK AND ACTUALLY.
LICENSE THE BUSINESSES THE LEGAL
BUSINESSES IN THEIR AREA SO
ABOUT INCENTIVIZING WE MAPPED
JUST TO USE.
LEGITIMATE LICENSED DISTRIBUTORS.
FOR DELIVERY.
AND WE MET US DON'T DO DELIVERY
SIR HELL NO OFFENSE. OUT OF
STORY OKAY.
OKAY.
THAT ADVERTISE WITH THEM.
THAT ON THE UPSIDE I TAKE THAT
BACK ON THE ADVERTISING SO I
GUESS THAT NOTHING GOOD COMMENT
BUT IF WE COME TO COMPLIANCE WE
TALK ABOUT COMPLIANCE HERE. IN
READ MAPS SHOULD ALSO LET FOLKS
THAT ARE LICENSED.
FOR DELIVERY ON THEIR MAPS AND
ALERTS YOU KNOW I'M SAYING.
YOU GET IT MIGHT JUST RIGHT
SWITCH ALL COMMITTEE COMPLIANCE
THAT WOULD BE VERY NICE.
SO THIS PINNACLES PUBLIC COMMENT.
THERE'S NO FOOD QUESTIONS WITH
GOV EUROPE I DON'T HAVE A
QUESTION BUT I THINK.
THAT ONE OF THE THE BIGGEST
ISSUES IS HOW DO WE GET THE
LOCAL.
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO WORK IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THAT DOJ
BECAUSE.
IP WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO SHUT
DOWN THAT THAT BLACK MARKET IF
WE'RE GONNA REALLY SEE THE
NUMBERS IMPROVE IN TERMS OF. OF.
REVENUE COMING IN AND LICENSING
LICENSES.
BEING OBTAINED AND THE WHOLE
ISSUE OF WHETHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE GOING TO ALLOW.
A DISPENSARIES ARE NOT WE LEAVE
UP TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO TO
KIND OF WORK OUT I THINK ONCE
THEY SEE THAT THERE'S A BENEFIT
THEN THEY'LL COME ON BOARD I
THINK SOME OF THEM WERE JUST
REALLY NERVOUS ABOUT THE WHOLE
THINKS BUT I. I REALLY WANT TO
SUPPORT THE. THE IDEA THAT WE
CREATED AN OPPORTUNITY TO FIND
LOCAL AND FORCE ME TO DO SOME OF
THE WORK AS WELL OR IT WILL COME
DOWN TO WE'VE THIRTY THREE
PERCENT OF CITIES THAT DO IT
RIGHT NOW THEIR LICENSE SO. WHEN
A POLICY OR SEVENTY SOME PERCENT
I MEAN THIS.
YOU GOT GOT A THREE RIDE TO THAT.
JUST BECAUSE DON'T AGREE WITH
THAT METHOD.
SO.
WE'RE RECOMMENDATION LA DOT THE
MAYBE VISION PROPOSAL AMID THE
DOJ PROPOSAL TO FUND IT FROM THE
GENERAL FUND NOT PROP SIXTY FOUR.
ADOPT TWENTY FINALLY FOR GRANTS
TO LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND UP
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
NOPE SORRY WE HAD TO FIND ALLOW
ME TO THINK MY IDEAS CAN I'D
SINCE IT'S.
GENERAL FUND RESOURCES THAT
DEVIATE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FISCAL PLAN WE
WOULD BE IN OPPOSITION AND I
WILL BE HAPPY TO HEAR MORE
DETAILS ON THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT PIECE AND HOW THAT'S
GONNA BE FUNDED BECAUSE THAT'LL
BE IMPORTANT TO. WHAT POSITION
WE TAKE DOING NOTED DR WOODS IT
WAS AS WELL THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY ONCE
AGAIN I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT?
MY ISSUE IS AROUND CULTIVATION
I REPRESENT AN AREA THAT MIGHT
MY DISTRICT ABOUT SIXTY TO
SEVENTY PERCENT PER HISTORICALLY
OF CANNABIS CULTIVATION IS
HAPPEN IN THAT DISTRICT. AND
WHAT WAS WHAT WAS STRIKING TO ME
AND THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL THE REALLY OTHER THAN
THE FIELD OFFICE WHICH WILL BE
ESTABLISHING EUREKA THERE REALLY
ISN'T ANY MONEY FOR ENFORCEMENT
THERE. AND SO MY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HUMBLE COUNTY IN
PARTICULAR.
ONCE NEEDS THE RESOURCES
ACTUALLY GO OUT AND FORCE AND
THEY DON'T HAVE IT AND SO THAT
WAS TO US THAT WAS A GLARING
GLARING. OMISSION AND.
AND OF GREAT CONCERN TO MY
DISTRICT SOME TYPE OF THANK YOU
FOR SUCH A LARGE WOODS.
SO WE'LL MOTION.
WELL FIRST AND SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE COOPER I THROW.
CABALLERO.
CHIU.
CHOI.
NO WE WILL CATCH UP WITH MISTER
BERLIN THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR.
SO THE MOTION ON ITEMS.
ONE THREE THREE NINE ELEVEN TO
TWELVE FOURTEEN SIXTEEN.
BROKE.
WELL THE LAST WEEK AFTER NINE
NINE ELEVEN AND TWELVE.
FOURTEEN AND SIXTEEN.
THAT'S FIVE ZERO AND THEN ITEMS
TEN THIRTEEN OF FIFTEEN.
BROWN NOW.
AND THEN ITEM NUMBER TWO
.
I HAVE A FAMILY.
GOOGLE.
UNLESS I'M SORRY WERE TO
LEGISLATIVE WORKLOADS.
THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
.
THAT ACTION AND CHAIR MEMBERS I
MY NAME IS JENNIFER URBAN WITH
THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE.
BOTH SICK COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
IS REQUESTING ONE TWO YEAR
LIMITED TERM POSITION AND TO
PERMANENT RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
NEW MANDATED STATEWIDE
ACCOUNTING REQUIREMENTS.
FOUR PIECES OF RECENTLY PASSED
LEGISLATION REQUIRE INCREASED
WORK ON THE PART OF THE SCO
ACCOUNTING FUNCTIONS. IN ORDER
TO PREPARE CASH TRANSFERS LOAN
PRINCIPAL AND INTEREST PAYMENTS.
ESTABLISH AND MAINTAIN INTER
FUND LOAN PAYABLES AND
RECEIVABLES AND VARIOUS OTHER
ACCOUNTING ADJUSTMENTS.
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
A DEAL IF.
GENUINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS
NEAL AND INCREASE THE COUNTY
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH SP ONE
SPD FOR PROFIT THE SIX AND PROP
SIXTY FOUR.
LL.
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING THAT
ONE OF THESE THREE POSITIONS BE
FUNDED SOLELY WITH GENERAL FUND
ALTHOUGH THAT POSITION WILL BE
PERFORMING STATEWIDE
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS. ON
TYPICALLY THESE POSITIONS WILL
BE FUNDED WITH A MIX OF GENERAL
FUND AND CENTRAL SERVICE COST
RECOVERY FUND. AND WE THINK THAT
THAT APPROPRIATE MAKE SHOULD BE
USED IN THIS CASE AS WELL.
THE QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
THEY WON THE PUBLIC WHICH IS BIG
ON THIS ITEM.
CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PROVE A
MAJOR REVISION PROPOSAL THEIR
MOTION.
WELL THE FIRST AND SECOND ROLL
CALL PLEASE COOPER AYE PRO.
CABALLERO.
CHIU.
JOINT.
CAN THIS ONE ISSUE NUMBER THREE
A CALIFORNIA STATE PAYROLL
SYSTEM.
SEE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE REQUEST
TO CONTINUE NINETEEN EXISTING
RESOURCES AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
TO SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PAYROLL SYSTEM PROJECT IN STAGE
TWO OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY. PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFE CYCLE.
ELEVEN OF THE NINETEEN RESOURCES
ARE REQUESTED AS PERMANENT. TO
SUPPORT CORE PROJECT WORKED
THROUGH THE DURATION OF THE CS
PS PROJECT.
THIS REQUEST ALSO INCLUDES FIVE
NEW TO YOUR LIMITED TERM
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT STATEWIDE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AN EMPLOYEE
SELF SERVICE PORTAL WEB
APPLICATION ALSO KNOWN AS
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYEE CONNECT.
FINANCE.
WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO
CONTINUE THAT REPLACEMENT EFFORT
FOR THE PAYROLL SYSTEM INCLUDING
THAT THE DEVELOPMENT OF FEATURES
AND STATEWIDE.
SERVICE WEB PORTAL APPLICATION
OIL.
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PREVIOUS RESOURCES
ON A TWO YEAR LIMITED TERM BASIS
AND ADOPT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO BETTER ALIGN.
THE PLANNING PROCESS FOR THIS.
PAYROLL PROJECT WITH THE BUDGET
PROCESS AND WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THE LEGISLATURE HAS A
MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH
IN WITH ITS OWN PRIORITIES FOR
THIS IT PROJECT WHICH COULD
POTENTIALLY BE.
VERY COMPLEX AND COSTLY IN THE
FUTURE THANK YOU FOR THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE IF THESE
ITEMS ARE APPROVED. HOW THIS
PROCESS ALLOW FOR LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT MOVING FORWARD? YEAH
SO WE RESPECT THE ELLIOTTS
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS PROPOSAL.
COVER WE DO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE COMMITTEE
CONSIDER OUR REQUEST IS BUDGETED
OUR PROPOSAL AS REQUESTED ALLOWS
FOR ANNUAL REVIEW AND OVERSIGHT
BY THE LEGISLATURE.
THE CURRENT REQUEST DOES NOT
INCLUDE FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
PROJECT EVEN THROUGH THE
COMPLETION OF STAGE TO.
THEREFORE THE BEST YOU WILL BE
BACK IN FRONT OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AS EARLY AS NEXT SPRING TO
REPORT ON THE PROGRESS OF THE
PROJECT INTO SECURE RESOURCES TO
COMPLETE A STAGE TO.
THEREFORE WE BELIEVE IT IS
UNNECESSARY TO LIMIT THE
PERMANENT RESOURCE
A PORTION OF THIS REQUEST WHICH
WILL SUPPORT THE COR PROJECT.
THROUGH THE DURATION OF THE
PROJECT.
IF ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE.
THROW THINGS CHAIR.
.
WOULD THE LEGISLATURE BE
CONSIDERED AS PART OF THE SYSTEM.
OF THE PAYROLL SYSTEM YES.
OKAY BECAUSE ONE FRUSTRATION I
HAVE THIS EVERY WEEK
I GET A FRANK ENVELOPE FROM THE
CONTROLLER WITH THAT PER DIEM
PACE AT WHICH.
I THINK IT'S HUGE WASTE PAPER ON
HOW DOES THAT DOES EVERY STATE
EMPLOYEE GET.
HARPIST TUBS OF PAPER STUBS
CURRENTLY.
YES THEY DO.
THAT WOULD BE THE SECOND PART
OF THE CS PS REQUESTS WE HAVE A
FIVE POSITION REQUEST TO
CONTINUE THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF ARC HELM PLAY
CONNECT PORTAL.
THE PORTAL ACTUALLY.
.
WE HAVE A PROTOTYPE BUILT ITS IN
PILOT INSIDE OF US CO RIGHT NOW
AND IT DOES ALLOW FOR THE
REPLACEMENT OF THE PRINTING OF
THE DIRECT DEPOSIT ADVICES FOR
ALL EMPLOYEES.
INCLUDING CSU.
BUT THE PLAN IS TO.
OFFER THAT STATEWIDE SOMETIME
IN TWENTY NINETEEN ONCE WE'RE
DONE WITH OUR PILOT AND TESTING.
OKAY SO THAT YOUR GOAL TO
ULTIMATELY GET INTO A SYSTEM
ROCKET LAGAAN IF I DON'T KNOW IF
I GET A HOME LOAN I CAN PRINT
OUT TWO MONTHS OF.
PAY STUBS AYE DON'T NEED TO GET
PAPER COPIES EVERY NOT THAT THIS
IS YOUR GOAL DIRECTED YOU CAN
ACTUALLY TO SAVE AN IMAGE OF IT.
IF YOU EVER NEED TO.
AND AGAIN THESE THINGS ARE
THESE ARE THINGS WE WANT TO DO
IN ADVANCE OF THE C. S. B. S.
PROJECT THAT IS IN ANY TWENTY
NEXT YEAR YOU'RE CONSIDERING
DOING THIS WE'RE LOOKING AT
TWENTY NINETEEN IMPLEMENTATION
OF THAT SERVICE.
IT'S GREAT NEWS THAT I ACTUALLY
USE THAT SERVICE MY PURPLE
EFFECT NO COUNTY YOU WAS THE
FACT IF. EMPLOYEES GOING ON IN
THE JUST GET THE PAPER HITS A
SERIOUS.
WE'VE SPEND APPROXIMATELY A
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR RIGHT NOW
PRUNING DIRECT DEPOSIT ADVICES
AND ANOTHER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND A YEAR PUTTING W. TO.
SELECT AND ASSIST REQUEST ON A
LOT OF THIS IS A CONSIDERATION
FOR. OUR CHANGING IMPROVING THAT
PEER OR SYSTEM PER SE NOT THE
INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
MONEY. CORRECT.
CALVET A PUBLIC CONCERT YOU.
AT FIRST I APPRECIATE MR PEROT'S
QUESTION THAT'S SOMETHING I
THINK ALL OF A SUDDEN WONDER
ABOUT FOR AWHILE.
.
SO THE LA IS RECOMMENDING THAT.
WE REJECT THE ONGOING PROPOSAL
IN PART SO THAT WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN ON.
FOR ALTERNATIVES TO THE PROJECT
SO.
BECAUSE I TRY TO READ THIS AND
THERE'S A LOT OF BUREAUCRATIC
LANGUAGE IN IT.
HOW WE ACTUALLY TO HAVE INPUT
INTO ALTERNATIVE IF YOU CAN JUST
BEFORE WITH AN HONOR YOUR
PROPOSED YEAH WE WE CANNOT MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS PROJECT
WITHOUT YOUR APPROVAL WE'VE WE?
?
MUST COME BACK PRETTY MUCH EVERY
YEAR TO REQUEST RESOURCES I'M
ALREADY FORMING NEXT YEAR'S
REQUEST.
YOU WILL DEFINITELY HERE YOU
KNOW STATUS UPDATES ONCE WE HAVE
YOU KNOW MEANINGFUL NO
INFORMATION REPORT. SO YEAH I
HAVE EVERY YEAR YOU WILL HEAR
FROM OUR OUR PROJECT CIVIL WITH
ELIO SAY THAT.
SO WE ALSO INCLUDED A
RECOMMENDATION THAT THEY.
THAT THE SCO WOULD COME BACK IN
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY I WITH THE
RESULTS FROM STAGE TO ANALYSIS.
AND WE DID THAT BECAUSE IMPART
WE.
.
THINK IT MAKES SENSE FOR THE SCO
TO COME BACK IN JANUARY
SPECIFICALLY RATHER THAN MAY.
AND ONE CONCERN THAT WE WOULD
HAVE IS THAT THE REQUEST WOULD
COME IN MAY IN THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD HAVE ONLY A FEW DAYS.
OUGHT TO CONSIDER IT AND TO
THINK OVER THESE VERY COMPLEX
ALTERNATIVES BEFORE MAKING A
DECISION WHICH IS A FEELS LIKE
RIGHT NOW.
OKAY.
I HAVE SEEN TORRENT AYE I. THINK
YOUR DEPARTMENT KNOWS MY GENERAL
PERSPECTIVE ON A LOT OF THESE
PROJECTS NOT SPECIFIC TO YOUR
OFFICE BUT. NAM.
I DO LIKE THE IDEA BEEN ABLE TO
COME BACK A LITTLE BIT EARLIER
AND JUST ASK AND WANT TO KNOW
FROM THE CHAIR WHAT YOUR
THOUGHTS ARE ON THIS LIKE I
COULD PROBABLY GO EITHER WAY BUT
YOU'RE. BRING A LITTLE OKAY SO
THAT.
MIKE DEVLIN TOP OF THE OFF LINE.
A PUBLIC COMING THIS ITEM.
CAL CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT RICK
RECOGNITION TO HOLD OPEN.
NEXT MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR AUTOMATED TRAVEL EXPENSE
REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM.
THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
REQUEST ONE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
SEVEN HUNDRED FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS THROUGH TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO TO SUPPORT FOUR POINT
FIVE FOUR YEAR LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS. THAT WILL ALLOW THE
S. HERE TO FINALIZE THE
CALENDARS REPLACEMENT.
EFFORT PROJECT APPROVAL BY CYCLE
STAGE THREE AND STAGE FOUR AS
WELL AS WORK WITH THE
REPLACEMENT BENDER TO PREPARE
THE NEW SOLUTION FOR STATEWIDE
ROLL OUT.
FINANCE.
WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO
ADDRESS WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
THE CALENDAR SYSTEM DOYLE.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THE RESOURCES REQUESTED HERE ON
BUT THE ADMINISTRATION ALSO
PROPOSES BUDGET THE LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD ALLOW DO AFT TO
AUGMENT AS CIOS ITEM.
IF THERE ARE NEW FEATURES OF A
SYSTEM OR ON SOMETHING ELSE THAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO ADD TO THE
CONTRACT WITH IBM WE THINK A
LITTLE BIT OF FLEXIBILITY MAKES
SENSE BUT THAT THAT THERE SHOULD
BE A CAP ON THE AMOUNT OF
FLEXIBILITY THIS GIVEN TO DO YOU
HAVE. WE'RE RECOMMENDING A CAP
OF TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
BUT OTHER AMOUNTS WOULD ALSO BE
REASONABLE.
ANY QUESTIONS NICK
COMMITTEE.
MY QUESTION PUBLIC COMMENTS.
OKAY RECOGNITION TO PROVE THE
MAYBE VISION PROPOSAL IS OUR
MOTION.
BUT FIRST THE SECOND OR LOCAL
POLICE COOPER HI BRO.
CAMARO.
CHIU.
CHOI NO.
CRITICS ASTRONOMER FIVE REMOVE
REFILL DATE FOR TAX DATA
EXCHANGE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
.
GOOD AFTERNOON AYE JAY CHAIRMAN
DEPARTMENT PLANETS.
HOME.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND INTO THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD HAS HAD
STATUTORY AUTHORITY. TO ENTER
INTO RECIPROCAL AYE DATA SHARING
AGREEMENT FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
FLOOD THE DATA SURE DATA SHARING
ASSIST YOU HAVE TO BE AN
INSURANCE INCOME TAX COMPLIANCE
AND ASSIST LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
INSURANCE COMPLIANCE WITH A CITY
BUSINESS TAX REQUIREMENTS.
PRINCESS TAX WERE CURRENTLY HAS
ENTERED INTO DATA SHOULD SHARING
AGREEMENTS WITH SEVENTY FOUR
CITIES.
FOR THE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN FISCAL YEAR THEY HAVE
TO BE COLLECTED OVER TEN MILLION
FROM PERSONAL INCOME TAX AND
CORPORATE TAXPAYERS. IDENTIFIED
OF USINGTHE DATA FROM THE
SEVENTY FOUR CITIES.
ADDITIONALLY THE PARTICIPATING
CITIES HAVE OBTAINED SIGNIFICANT
REVENUE AS WELL. IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF TWENTY MILLION
OR MORE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW OF FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD FORTY TO ENTER INTO
DATA SHARING AGREEMENTS.
ENDS AT THE END OF THIS YEAR.
OTHER FOR WITHOUT A STATUTORY
CHANGE THIS PROVEN METHOD OF
IDENTIFYING NON COMPLIANCE AND
GENERATING STATE LOCAL REVENUE
WILL BE LOST INCREASING THAT THE
TAX BURDEN ON COMPLY TAXPAYERS.
HOW THE TEXTURED A BILL WHICH
SIMPLY REMOVE THE SUNSET DATE
FROM THE STATUTE?
WOULD GIVE RETROSPECT WOULD
CONTINUE AUTHORITY TO ENTER INTO
THESE A DATA SHARING AGREEMENTS.
POTENTIAL QUESTIONS
THANK YOU HELLO. A WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL
FRANCHISE.
IN GOOD NO COMMENT THINK.
OKAY YOU QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
AND RIVER THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
KILL CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADOPT PLACE
WILL TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS
OUR MOTION.
WELL FIRST AND SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE COOPER I GROW JOINT.
CRITICS THAT THE OTHER NUMBER
SIX A CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JEANNIE HERMAN
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD PUBLIC
DETECTIVE FEW QUICK MINUTES TO
PROVIDE YOU SOME UPDATED STOPS
IN REGARDS TO THE EARNED INCOME
TAX PROGRAM TO DATE.
I'M AS OF. MAY TWELFTH
WE HAVE PROCESS ONE POINT THREE
MILLION RETURNS CLAIMING THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT.
FOR THREE HUNDRED AND THREE
MILLION DOLLARS INTO
CALIFORNIANS POCKET.
NINETY SIX PERCENT OF THOSE
RETURNS FILED HAD NO FILING
REQUIREMENT BUT THE MAJORITY OF
THEM ARE ONGOING FILERS WITH
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD IN AN
ATTEMPT TO RETURN THAT THEY'RE
WITHHOLDING REFUND THAT IS DUE
TO THEM.
OF THAT GROUP ONLY TEN PERCENT
ARE BASICALLY FIRST TIME FILERS
LESS THAN A HUNDRED OR JUST OVER
A HUNDRED AND SIX THOUSAND OR
FIRST TIME PILAR'S.
SENATE MAJORITY OF INDIVIDUALS
CLAIMING THE CREDIT ARE IN FACT
DO NOT HAVE A FILING REQUIREMENT.
FOR CALIFORNIA.
NINETY FIVE PERCENT EFILE.
SHE PERCENT USE A PAPER PAIR.
PROVIDE US FORTY TWO THOUSAND
RETURNS WERE CLAIMED FOR FILED
THIS YEAR CLAIMING THE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT. FOR CAL FILE
F. TIBI'S RETURN PROGRAM SAY
THOUSAND RETURNS WERE FILED
CLAIMING VITA.
FREQUENT QUESTION WE GET AS FAR
AS BREAKING DOWN THE UNIVERSE
BETWEEN SELF EMPLOYMENT AND WAY
EACH.
SIXTY EIGHT PERCENT OF THE
CREDITS CLAIMED ARE RELATED TO
WAGE FAVORS AND THIRTY TWO
PERCENT ARE RELATED TO SELF
EMPLOYMENT INCOME FILERS.
TO PLAY HIM UP AFTER ANY. JUST.
PLANTS.
ARM SO OUR ARMY REVISION
PROPOSAL WAS IS TO EXPAND THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT.
TO INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT
DEPENDENTS WHO ARE UNDER AGE
TWENTY FIVE OF THE OVER EIGHTEEN
AND UNDER AGE TWENTY FIVE AND
WHO ARE OVER SIXTY FIVE.
.
AND ADDITIONALLY WE WERE WE ARE
PROPOSING TO.
I INCREASE THE MAXIMUM OF THAT
ARE THE WAGE DE INCOME LEVEL AT
WHICH THE A CREDIT PHASES OUT TO
A.
THE EQUIVALENT OF A FULL TIME
WAGE OF AT A TWELVE DOLLARS PER
HOUR WHICH IS.
THE END OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
MINIMUM WAGE.
LL.
A HOME WE NOTED.
EARLIER THIS YEAR THAT THE.
ASIDE FROM NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE
FRANCHISE TAX WHAT'S BUDGET
THERE IS NO ADDITIONAL. FUNDING
FOR EITC EDUCATION OUTREACH
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
COMING OUT THAT THE.
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS FOR
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
ADDITIONAL OUTREACH AND FREE TAX
PREPARATION SERVICES.
AND.
IF YOU HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
ABOUT THOSE GUYS FROM PRIOR
YEARS WERE PREPARED TO ANSWER.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE.
THE QUESTIONS FOR THE PUBLIC OR
COMMENTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE STILL
PREVENTS THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE
FUND CALIFORNIA ALSO
REPRESENTING MORE THAN TWENTY
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE CALLIOPE DC
ADVOCACY COALITION. A WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
YOUR CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON
KELLY IDC. AND WE KNOW THAT THIS
IS A REALLY EFFECTIVE WAY TO
GIVE.
WORKING POOR FAMILIES. WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET
MORE INCOME IN THEIR POCKET?
AND WE APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL IN MAY
REVISED TO INCLUDE THE YOUNG
ADULTS AND THE SENIORS AS WELL
AS MINIMUM WAGE WORKERS IN THE
IN THE KELLY IDC. UMBER WE
STRONGLY.
ADDITIONALLY ENCOURAGE AS THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION INCLUDES ON
THE INCLUSION OF IMMIGRANT
WORKERS.
WHO ARE PAYING TAXES I'M FILING
TAXES I'M AND SHOULD BE INCLUDED?
AND IN THE END NOT EXCLUDED
FROM THIS POLICY.
WE ADDITIONALLY REALLY STRONGLY
SUPPORT ON THE INCLUSION OF
MONEY FOR OUTREACH AND.
FREE TAX PREPARATION WE NOW
KNOW HOW EFFECTIVE THIS PROGRAM
IS THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR FAMILIES.
WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
PROGRAM ARE ACTUALLY RECEIVING
IT ON IN THIS FUNDING IS GOING
TO GO LONG WAY TO ENSURING I
THINK YOU?
DAN BROUGHT DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME THEY EVERYTHING SHE SAID.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE RECOGNITION IS APPROVAL SO.
A CHRISTOPHER GOLLY ON ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA GOOD POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT OF THE.
GOVERNOR'S I MAY REVISE
PROPOSAL AS WELL AS THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION I IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES HAVE CONTRIBUTE
BILLIONS TO OUR STATE ECONOMY.
THIS AYE RECOMMENDATION MAKES
SENSE.
FOR.
BITING HOLDERS TO FOLKS WHO
WILL LOSE THE AUTHORIZATION ON.
DOC WORK AUTHORIZATION AYE
DHAKA'S RESCINDED AS WELL AS TPS
I CAN AND TRANSPORT OF THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU.
ON A HOUSE OF LED BY THE UNITED
REYES CALIFORNIA I WILL ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES.
AND WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE.
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE PROPOSAL
AS WELL AS THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
ON EXTENDING THE.
.
BUT CREDIT TO IMMIGRANT WORKERS.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS I JUST
WANNA QUICKLY HIGHLIGHT IS THE
NEED FOR OUTREACH AND THE
VOLUNTEER IN PERSON TAX
ASSISTANCE.
IT'S.
.
ESPECIALLY AS THE VAST MAJORITY
OF ELIGIBLE WORKERS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO FILE THEIR TAXES
BECAUSE THEIR INCOME IS SO LOW
BECAUSE OF THE RECENT FEDERAL
TAX LAW EVEN FEWER FAMILIES WILL
BE REQUIRED TO FILE THE FEDERAL
TAXES. SO WE KNOW THAT MORE
OUTREACH.
FROM TRUSTED COMMUNICATORS IN
THE IN.
INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITIES IS
REALLY IMPORTANT.
AND AND ENSURING THAT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD YOU WANT
IN PERSON ASSISTANCE ARE ABLE TO
RECEIVE IT RIGHT NOW WE ARE I'M
SEEING EXTENSIVE WAIT TIMES.
FROM FOUR TO SIX WEEKS OFF FOR
THAT.
IN PERSON ASSISTANCE AND SO WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO EXTEND.
EXPAND THAT ASSISTANCE AS WELL
AS.
THE ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE
EFFECTIVELY TO THOSE COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS ANOTHER DONE WITH
THE WHITE IMMIGRANT REPRESENTING
NEXT ON CALIFORNIA BEAR IN THIS
VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION SPECIALLY THAT
ONE. I EXPANSION FOR LOW INCOME
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES THE.
IF YOU.
ANGELINA OF ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT ME TOO WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU.
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE AND
THANKFULFOR THE MAYBE VISION TO
EXPAND THE EIGHTEEN TWENTY FOUR
YEAR OLDS AND SENIORS.
WE DO FEEL LIKE THERE'S MORE
WORK TO BE DONE ADDITIONAL WORK
IS REFLECTED IN A RECOMMENDATION.
I RECOGNITION TO PROVE THE
GOVERNOR'S NAY VISION PEOPLE IN
ADDITION.
IT'S BEEN EITC TO COVER LOW
INCOME WORKING IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES.
FEDERALLY ASSIGNED INDIVIDUAL
TAXPAYER ID NUMBERS OR SO
SECURITY NUMBERS. AND TWENTY
MILLION FOR ADDITIONAL OUT REACH
FREE TAX PREPARATION SERVICES.
AS OUR MOTION COMFY. APART YET
YOU JUST I I'D LIKE A TO POP FOR
THE RECORD SAKE THAT WE WERE
OPPOSED TO THE EXPANSION.
TWO OF TAXPAYERS WITH WHO
WITHOUT PELLETS OF SCURVY
NUMBERS BECAUSE OF THE REVENUE
COSTIN BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME
ISSUES THAT THAT. COULD WITH
SOME OF THOSE RETURNS IT COULD
LEAD TO HIGHER IMPROPER PAYMENTS
DULY NOTED.
I JUST WANNA CZECHO ECHO WHAT
THE CHARGES SAID IN A PARTICULAR.
I APPRECIATE EXPANSION THE ITC
TO COVER WORKING IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES THIS IS SOMETHING WE
DISCUSSED.
VIC A COUPLE WEEKS AGO AND I
THINK
A VERY NOT WELCOME.
CHANGE TO THE SO FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE.
IT'S MADE BETTER AND I'M HAPPY
TO TO SPORTS STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
WE.
SO REPUBLIC.
COOPER I FROM.
CABALLERO.
CHIU.
CHOI.
OKAY TEXAS TO OUR MOTION PASSES
THE THE STORE NEXT OF ISSUE
SEVEN CTF A REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
SELF TECH INVENTION TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
OKAY ARMED.
TRY TO KEEP THIS SHORT I. IT DID
SUB.
THIS OUR HOME IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN. OF THE GOVERNOR'S
INITIATIVE.
HOME.
TO TO CHANGE THE TAX CODE TO
ENCOURAGE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CALIFORNIA WAS ENACTED. PART OF
THAT A.
PACKAGE WAS IN WIZARD NEW
MANUFACTURING OR AS CELLS TAKE
POSITION FOR MANUFACTURING
EQUIPMENT.
ARM AND IN THAT LEGISLATION THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION WAS
REQUIRED TO DO NINE REPORT AND
PART OF THAT ANNUAL REPORT
MISSED.
WAS TO COMPARE. THE ORIGINAL
ESTIMATE OF HOW MUCH
OF THE EXEMPTION WOULD BE USED
WITH HOW MUCH WAS ACTUALLY BEING
USED.
AND THEN.
IF.
.
IF IF THOUGH A SMALL AMOUNT IS
BEING USED TO COME UP WITH A
LIST OF OPTIONS FOR EXPANDING
THE USAGE OF THE CREDIT.
I'M.
THERE IS A LAST YEAR WITH THE
ADOPTION OF AB ONE OR TWO WHICH
TRANSFERRED SOME OF THE WAYS
RESPONSIBILITIES.
TO DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION AND WITH A.
THE DOBSON VB THREE NINETY EIGHT
WHICH WHICH EXPANDED.
.
VIA THE SELL SEX EXEMPTION.
THERE'S INADVERTENT LANGUAGE
CHANGE OR INADVERTENT CHANGE THE
MEANING OF THE LANGUAGE SO THAT
NOW HAS IT READS IT SAYS THE
DEPARTMENT THAT.
CD TFA IS SUPPOSED TO COMPARE
ACTUAL USAGE WITH.
THE THEIR MOST CURRENT ESTIMATE
SO DOESN'T REALLY GIVE THE
DOESN'T FULFILL THE. ORIGINAL
MEANING SO WE PROPOSE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD.
CLARIFY THAT WIN WIN CDT A PHASE
MAKING THAT COMPARISON. IT'S
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ORIGINAL ESTIMATE AND NOT WITH
THEIR CURRENT ASSESSMENT.
AND ALSO THAT OF THE LIST OF
OPTIONS SINCE THAT THAT OPS THE
LIST OF OPTIONS HAS BEEN.
I DELIVERED TO THE. HOME JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE FOR
FOUR YEARS IN A ROW THERE'S NO
NEED TO CONTINUE WITH THAT LIST.
CAN AND THAT'S IT OUR PROPOSAL
THANK YOU ELLIOTT. WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL.
A QUESTION THE COMMITTEE.
NICHOLAS IN THE PUBLIC.
THOUGHT CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT
REGULATIONS TO ADOPT THE
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE
IS THERE A MOTION.
BUT A MOTION A SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE COOPER I GROW.
CABALLERO.
CHIU.
CHOI.
MOTION PASSES.
NEXT ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT.
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
PROCUREMENT
.
THE.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
CHRIS TRUE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY.
MY HAVE HURTS MY RIGHT.
THE MAP VENDOR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES.
AND I ALSO WANT TO INTRODUCE
RUSS NICHOLS WHO IS THE AGENCY
CHIEF INFORMATION OFFICER OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
HE'S A PART OF OUR IT OF
EXECUTIVE COUNCIL WHICH IS OUR
STATE LIKE GOVERNMENT'S POLICY
TO EFFECTUATE IT POLICY HERE
CALIFORNIA.
ERIC THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY RIGHT
REGARDING THIS IMPORTANT TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE ON IT PROCUREMENT.
AGAIN I'M JOINED BY IDG US TO
SEE THE TEARS WERE
COLLABORATIVELY WITH ON TRAILER
BILL. AS WELL AS RUSS NICHOLS
AND THE AGENCY CHIEF INFORMATION
OFFICER AS PART OF OUR IT
EXECUTIVE COUNCIL.
THIS PROPOSAL WILL LEVERAGE THE
EXPERTISE THE BOAT DE GEASS AND
CBT AND CREATE IMPROVE OUTCOMES
FOR STATE INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
PROJECTS.
THE MODEST CHANGES REFLECTED IN
THIS TWO BILLS CONSISTENT WITH
THE EVOLUTION OF CD TEASE ROLE
OF PROVIDING STATEWIDE STRATEGIC
DIRECTION FOR INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY PROJECTS.
CBT HAS EXISTING STATUTORY
AUTHORITY FOR OVERSIGHT
PROCUREMENTS OF REPORTABLE IT
PROJECTS PRIOR TO PROJECTS
IMPLEMENTATION.
BUT NOT DURING PROJECT
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS PHASE.
DRESSED IN THE GPL REFLECT THE
MODEST REALITY OF MODERN REALITY
OF THE ENTIRE LIFECYCLE OF
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY PROJECTS
FROM CONCEPT. PLANNING
PROCUREMENT IMPLEMENTATION AND
FINALLY TO MISSION MAINTENANCE
AND OPERATIONS AS WELL SOLUTION
RETIREMENT OF THE SYSTEM.
AS A RESULT THE CBO WILL ENABLE
CTT AUTHORITIES OVERSEEING
PICTURE GOODS AND SERVICES
RELATED TO IT PROJECTS DURING
THE MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS
PHASE. NOT JUST FROM AN IT
PROJECTS CONCEPT PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION PHASE.
ADDITIONALLY THE TPL ALIGN IT
PROCUREMENT FOR GOODS AND
SERVICES RELATED TAICHI PROJECTS
AS OPPOSED TO JUST REPORTABLE IT
PROJECTS.
ONLY IN FAVOR ANY NON DELEGATED
DELEGATED FRAMEWORK WE FEEL THAT
THIS PUTS
MORE QUALITY ASSURANCE MAJORS IN
PLACE AT THE PROJECT LEVEL FOR
CBT. AND ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
REHABILITATION TO NOT MAXIMIZING
MITIGATE RISK APPROPRIATELY WITH
THEIR PROJECTS AND ENSURE THE
PROJECT IS ON THE RIGHT TRACK
FIRST.
THIS TPL ALSO BRING CLARITY THE
ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES AND
LEVERAGE THE EXPERTISE OF GIGI
ASSN CDT FOR STATE AGENCIES AND
INCOMES WHEN PURCHASING GOODS
AND SERVICES FOR INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY RELATED PROJECTS.
ADDITIONALLY WE FEEL THAT THIS
TPL WILL PROVIDE SPECIFICALLY
THE FOLLOWING BENEFITS
DRAW A CLEAN AND CLEAR BRIGHT
LINE ON IT PROJECT RELATED
ACQUISITIONS.
FACILITATING INCREASE THE
STRATEGIC DIRECTIONS TO STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES AND
THEIR IT PROJECT PHASES.
FOCUSED UGS ACQUISITION
RESOURCES ON CONTAIN TO CREATE
STATEWIDE LEVERAGE AGREEMENTS
THAT ALIGN WITH THE STATE'S ON A
BROADER TECHNOLOGY STRATEGY.
AND SURE AND INTEGRATED APPROACH
TO STATEWIDE IT PROJECTS.
AVOID DUPLICATION OF EFFORT AND
MANAGE ACCOUNTABILITY WHICH
RESPONSIBILITY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION I'M GOING TO TURN
THIS OVER TO MY APARTMENT
OPPORTUNITY MATT BENDER FROM TGS
TO TALK ABOUT WHAT THIS AYE TPL
DOES NOT DO IN TERMS OF JESUS
RELATED PROCUREMENTS. AT HER OF
PERSONAL HISTORY OF BACK IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN WE TRANSFERRED
OUR RESPONSIBILITY FORMAJOR IT
PROJECT ACQUISITIONS.
FROM DTS TO THE PART OF
TECHNOLOGY I WAS ON THE TEAM
THAT DRAFTED THAT TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WHICH WAS.
A PART OF THE TWENTY THIRTEEN
MAY REVISION OF BACK IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN WHEN WE'RE DOING THAT
WE RECOGNIZE THAT. WHAT WE WERE
THE WORK WE WERE DOING THAT
WOULD PROBABLY NEED A LITTLE
FINE TUNING?
AFTER A FEW YEARS AFTER WE HAD
GOT GOTTEN SOME EXPERIENCE
OPERATING UNDER THIS NEW SYSTEM.
IN THAT SPIRIT.
DEVIOUS COLLABORATED WITH CTT
TO DEVELOP THE LANGUAGE THAT'S
BEFORE YOU TODAY. IT'S
RELATIVELY MODEST CHANGE.
TO EXISTING RULES
RESPONSIBILITIES BUT ONE THAT
STRENGTHENS A CD TEASE OVERSIGHT.
CDT IS GETTING A LITTLE MORE
AUTHORITY TO BE A CHECK AND
BALANCE ON IT PROJECT RELATED
ACQUISITIONS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
HANDLED BY CUSTOMER DEPARTMENTS.
TO BE CLEAR HOWEVER DTS WILL
CONTINUE TO CARRY OUT ITS
EXISTING RESPONSIBILITIES.
WHEN CUSTOMER AGENCIES CONDUCT
ACQUISITIONS LATE IT PROJECTS
WILL CONTINUE TO OPERATE WITHIN
THE SCOPE OF THEIR DELEGATIONS
FROM TGS.
DVS WILL CONTINUE TO SET LIMITS
AND STATE CONTRACTING MANUAL
PROCEDURES FOR THOSE
ACQUISITIONS.
I DID YES WILL ALSO CONTINUE TO
WARD AND ADMINISTER ALL IT
LEVERAGED PROCUREMENT AGREEMENTS.
AND I ALSO WANT TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT NOTHING IN THIS PROPOSAL
CHANGES A COMPETITIVE BIDDING
REQUIREMENTS THAT CURRENTLY
APPLY.
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS I'D ALSO LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE FROM DTS OR DIRECTOR
DANIEL KIM AND CHEAPER CURRENT
OFFICER. ANGELES SHELL WHO ARE
WITH US TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEARLY
FINANCE.
THAT RAN APARTMENT A FINANCE
THAT WE SUPPORT THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AS A CONTINUES TO.
LEVINE STATUE WITH THE EDGIER
P. NUMBER TWO.
WELL.
THERE THAT'S WHAT I LOVE LA WE
HAVE NO ISSUES TO RAISE FOR THE
COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MISTER CHIU.
I JUST DON'T WANT TO SAY I'M I'M
GLAD THAT EVERYONE IS HERE.
JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK
BOTH A ARTS CHAU NGUYEN AND THE
HEAD OF TGS FOR FOR BEING HERE
AS PART OF THIS DISCUSSION AND
BECAUSE THE TWO OF YOU ARE
TYPICALLY NOT IN THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE. I'LL JUST TAKE A
MOMENT.
TO TO DESCRIBE THE FACT THAT.
USUALLY EVERY OTHER WEEK IN THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE WE HAVE ANOTHER.
MAJOR PROJECT THAT IS TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ARE HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT'S
WOEFULLY BEHIND BUDGET AND
WOEFULLY BEHIND SCHEDULE AND WE.
ARE ALL VERY FRUSTRATED AT
WHAT'S HAPPENING A AND SO I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT THE TO YOUR
DEPARTMENTS ARE ARE ARE WORKING
TOGETHER. I THINK THIS IS
PROBABLY THE ONLY ISSUE WHERE I
HAVE REGULARLY AGREED WITH
MISTER TRAVIS ALLEN WHO HAS
SERVED ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE OF
THE FACT THAT WE'VE HAD A
MASSIVE WE NEED TO MOVE THINGS
FORWARD.
FOR MY PERSPECTIVE A I DO HAVE
FAITH THAT THIS IS MOVE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION BUT I DO ALSO
KNOW THIS IS.
AS I THINK ONE OF YOU DESCRIBED
IT A BIT OF A MODEST PROPOSAL.
AND.
MANY OF US HAVE EXPRESSED
FRUSTRATION.
AGAIN EVERY OTHER WEEK OR EVERY
THIRD WEEK ARE THAT THERE HAS
NOT BEEN MUCH WE CAN DO HERE IS
AN OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE ACCEPTED
JUST POINT OUT. WHAT'S NOT
HAPPENING AND SO I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY.
THAT THE TWO DEPARTMENTS.
HAMMING OUT WHAT YOU NEED TO IN
THIS AND AND CONTINUED.
CONTINUED PROGRESS ON THIS AND
AND CERTAINLY WE WILL BE
WATCHING AND MONITORING AND AND
SO OUR DEPARTMENT HAS ARE NOT
SURPRISED. I'VE ALMOST BEEN
AT THE POINT OF FRUSTRATION
WHERE I THOUGHT TO VOTE AGAINST
EVERY. A NEW.
EXPENDITURE.
THAT COMES ALONG ON A PROJECT
THAT HAS BEEN GOING FOR FOR
THREE FIVE SEVEN TEN YEARS ARE
BECAUSE WE'VE JUST SEEN NO END
IN SIGHT BUT. MY HOPE IS WERE
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
AND I DO IF I THINK THE TWO
DEPARTMENTS TALKING TO JOIN
HAMMER THIS. PROCESS OUT IS SO
IS A GOOD START.
WE'RE GOING UP THE PUBLIC
COMMENT EMOTIONS BEGIN THIS ITEM.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS REPTILES CLOSER I'VE A
VARIOUS NUMBER OF TECH CLIENTS
BUT A METHOD OF DOES ADD.
EXCUSE ME TONGUE TIED ON BEHALF
OF ADOBE THIS EVENING IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE ALSO LIKE TO
COMMEND. DOCTOR TONG AND HER
LEADERSHIP THAT SHE SHOULD OF
THE ORGANIZATION AND THE
SYMBIOTIC RELATIONSHIP THAT SHE
INDEED YES HAVE EXHIBITED THANK
YOU.
CHUCKLES PUBLIC COMMENT THE
RECOMMENDATION TO LIST ITEM
OPENS WILL HOLD OPEN.
VARTEC OF ISSUE NUMBER NINE SO
BRINGS US TO OUR LAST ITEM ISSUE
NUMBER TEN. THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS OUTREACH FUNDING
.
RECEIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF I AM
DE THIS KENTUCKY AND I AM.
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMPLETE COUNT SINCE TWENTY
TWENTY OFFICE UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING A
RESEARCH.
I'VE SERVED IN THE ROLE FOR THE
PAST USED ANNUAL CENSUSES AND I
AM THE CHAIR OF THE NATIONAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON RACE AT
THAT SEASON OTHER POPULATIONS.
TO THE U. S. CENSUS BUREAU.
SO THE TWENTY TWENTY EFFORT IS A
KEY INITIATIVE FAR STATE WHICH
IS WHY THE GOVERNOR INVESTED TEN
MILLION THIS LAST FISCAL YEAR TO
SUPPORT SINCE ITS EFFORTS.
SEVEN MILLION WENT TO THE LOCAL
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
INCENTIVIZE OUR PARTICIPATION IN
THE LOCAL.
UPDATE OF CENSUS ADDRESSES THE
LOCAL PROGRAM AND THREE MILLION
TO BEGIN BUILDING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE STATEWIDE
OUTREACH AND COMMUNICATIONS
EFFORT.
ADDING TO THE GOVERNOR'S CURRENT
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR FISCAL YEAR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN A FORTY POINT
THREE. MILLION DOLLARS BRINGS
CALIFORNIA'S TOTAL INVESTMENT TO
AN UNPRECEDENTED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
NO OTHER STATE IN THE NATION
COMES CLOSE.
TO THIS INVESTMENT OR IS IT
ADVANCE AS ADVANCED IN PLANNING
FOR THE DECENNIAL CENSUS CENSUS.
THIS FUNDING WILL BE
APPROPRIATED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND AVAILABLE FOR A
THREE YEAR EFFORT ENDING IN JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
CENSUS BUREAU ATTEMPTS TO COUNT
EVERY RESIDENT IN THE UNITED
STATES ONCE EVERY DECADE THE
NEXT GENERATION IS APRIL FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY AND I'LL BE THE
FIRST TIME THE CENSUS BUREAU
RELY HEAVILY ON ONLINE RESPONSES.
THE PRIMARY CHALLENGE FACING
CENSUS BUREAU CONTINUES TO BE
THE UNDERCOUNT A SPECIFIC
POPULATION GROUPS
FOREIGN BORN RESIDENTS
ESPECIALLY UNDOCUMENTED NON
WHITE RESIDENTS CHILDREN UNDER
FIVE YEARS OLD AND RENTERS
COMPRISE THE MOST UNDER COUNTY
POPULATIONS. AND CALIFORNIA HAS
MORE RESIDENTS IN EACH OF THESE
CATEGORIES THAN ANY OTHER STATE.
OF.
BUT WE WILL FACE AN EFFORTS OF
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGES THAT
YOU GUYS I THINK I KNOW ABOUT SO
WANTED JUST PROVIDES A BRIEF
HISTORY ON STATEWIDE PAST
EFFORTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY FOUR
POINT SEVEN MILLION WAS SPENT
DURING THE CRITICAL SIX MONTH
OUTREACH PROGRAM TIMEFRAME FROM
JUNE TO JANUARY TO JUNE TWO
THOUSAND. AND CALIFORNIA
OUTPACED THE ENTIRE NATION IN
OUR RESPONSE RATE.
REESE RECITE RE RECEIVED IN KIND
COMMITMENT AND SUPPORT FROM
STATE AGENCIES FOR LEGAL HUMAN
RESOURCES CONTRACTING
PROCUREMENT AS WELL AS OUTREACH
EFFORTS TO THE COMMUNITIES THAT
THEY SERVE.
WE STEP IS TO CALIFORNIA
COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEE THAT
WAS EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL IN
REACHING HARD TO COUNT
COMMITTEES COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT TRUSTED USING TRUSTED
MESSENGER ENGAGEMENT.
BUT THE TWENTY TEN CENSUS
CALIFORNIA APPOINTED A FIFTY TWO
MEMBER COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEE
AND OUTREACH DIRECTOR HOWEVER
DUE TO THE ONE OF THE WORST
RECESSIONS IN RECENT HISTORY
ONLY TWO MILLION IN FUNDS WERE
INVESTED IN THE PROGRAM.
MUCH OF THE SUCCESS OF TWENTY
TEN WAS ATTRIBUTED TO THE
PRIVATE INVESTMENT OF
FOUNDATIONS THAT FUNDED NEARLY
TEN MILLION. OF OUTREACH IN
ADVERTISING FROM THEIR OWN
COFFERS.
SINCE THE TWENTY TWENTY EFFORTS
WILL DEPLOY SIMILAR COMBINATIONS
OF APPROACHES PREVIOUSLY USE TO
REACH CALIFORNIA'S HARD TO COUNT
RESIDENTS.
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A WELL
CONNECTED LOCAL NETWORKS OF
TARGETED COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
AND TRUSTED MESSENGERS WE PARDON
OF EFFECTIVE OUTREACH IN
ADVERTISING EFFORT.
BY INVESTING IN RESEARCH AND
MESSAGE TESTING THE PAID
ADVERTISING AFRICAN ENSURE
RESIDENTS UNDERSTAND THE
CRITICAL NEED TO BE COUNTED AND
ENCOURAGE PARTICIPATION.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
DECENNIAL CENSUS IS A FEDERAL
OPERATION AND CALIFORNIA'S
ACTIVITIES WILL BE MODIFIED
BASED UPON THEIR OPERATIONAL.
ADVERTISING PARTNERSHIP AND
OUTREACH EFFORTS WHICH THEY ARE
CURRENTLY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS CURRENTLY BEING DEVELOPED AND
HAVE NOT FULLY ON DISCLOSED.
OVER THE LAST YEAR WE'VE
COLLABORATED PREVIOUSLY WITH
PREVIOUSLY ENGAGED PRIVATE
FOUNDATIONS TO DISCUSS A
STATEWIDE OUTREACH STRATEGY AND
BEST PRACTICES FOR AN EFFECTIVE
DEPLOYMENT.
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
UNPRECEDENTED VESPIDAE A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS PRIVATE
FOUNDATIONS ONE TO BE ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN CONCORDANT WITH US
AND THEY'RE CONSIDERING A MATCH
OF FUNDS.
THE STATE IS PREPARING AND
PLANNING TO ADDRESS NEW
CHALLENGES FOR A SUCCESSFUL.
TWENTY TWENTY I JUST WANNA SAY
THAT IN THE LAST FOUR WEEKS
WE'VE HANDLED SEVEN REGIONAL
CONVENIENCE ARE OUT OF THE THE
OVER TWENTY FIVE THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE DO IN THE NEXT TWELVE
WEEKS.
AND WE'RE ALSO GOING TO BETWEEN
TRIBAL CONSULTATIONS AND A WE
ALSO LOST OUR WEBSITE MY TEAM
AND I STAND READY TO PARTNER
WITH TRUSTED MESSENGERS ACROSS
THE STATE.
TO ENSURE A COMPLETE AND
ACCURATE COUNT OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I'LL
BE GLAD TO ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU
FINANCE.
THINK YOU'RE BECCA KIRK
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WANTED TO
REITERATE SOME OF MS DETAINEES
COMMENTS THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
DEFTLY RECOGNIZES THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS EFFORT.
I'M COMBINED WITH CURRENT YOUR
RESOURCES OF TEN MILLIONDOLLARS
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL.
REPRESENTS OF A REQUEST OF FIFTY
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR CENSUS ACTIVITIES WHICH IS
AS WITH PICKING MENTIONED A
HISTORIC STATE LEVEL INVESTMENT
MORE THAN TWICE THAT OF PREVIOUS
EFFORTS.
FURTHERMORE THE FUNDING THE
FORTY POINT THREE MILLION IN
THIS REQUEST OR IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS PROVIDED
FULLY IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TO ENSURE MAXIMUM
FLEXIBILITY THROUGHOUT THE THREE
YEAR EFFORT.
ALSO WE WANTED TO NOTE THAT THE
COMMITTEE STAFFS PROPOSED BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE WHICH WOULD ALLOW
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. TO
AUGMENT CENSUS FUNDING AND
POSITIONS IF NECESSARY DURING
THE FISCAL YEAR WOULD ENHANCE
THE ABILITY TO BE RESPONSIVE TO
ANY POTENTIAL NEED FOR CHANGES
MOVING FORWARD.
OUR PROPOSED UNPRECEDENTED
INVESTMENT BE FLEXIBILITY
INHERENT IN PROVIDING THE FUNDS
UP FRONT.
AND COMMITTEE STAFF PROPOSED
PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT RESOURCES AND
FLEXIBILITY AT THIS POINT IN
TIME.
REGARDING THE RECOMMENDED
INCREASE OF TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THIS EFFORT.
WE WOULD NEED ADDITIONAL TIME TO
DETERMINE WHETHER. THAT FUNDING
IS PRUDENT AT THIS TIME AND WHAT
IT WOULD NEED TO BE SPENT ON.
THANK YOU AND TO FOLLOW UP ON
THAT AND NUMBER ONE I'M
OBVIOUSLY THIS COMING UP IN IN
TWENTY TWENTY.
.
OF THOSE ROOKIES MISSIONS RECORD
FUNDING FOR THE CENSUS.
WITH ASSISTANCE OF ISSUE IN THE
INTERNET ISSUE OFF OF NOT HAVING
ACCESS INTERNET.
.
HOW MUCH MORE INFORMATION YOU
NEED TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT?
BUT AT THE CENTRAL FIGURE OUT
WITH ASSISTANCE SHOULD QUESTION
IT BEING A PART OF IT. A LOT OF
FOLKS NOT HAVING INTERNET JUST A
LOT OF FOLKS MY DISTRICT DON'T
HAVE IT.
S. ADVENTURE MY COLLEAGUES DON'T
SO.
THAT'S ARE NOT SURE HOW THAT
CONNECTS TOGETHER WITH MORE YOU
WOULD NEED.
RIGHT SO WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE IS UNCERTAINTY IN THIS
EFFORT PARTICULARLY FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS GIVEN AS
YOU MENTIONEDA COUPLE OF. A NEW
ELEMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN THROWN
INTO THE MIX.
WE DO FEEL THOUGH THAT GIVING
THAT FUNDING UP FRONT WOULD
ALLOW YOU KNOW REGARDLESS OF THE
PROPOSED BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
THERE WOULD BE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO COME BACK IF
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WERE NEEDED
BASED ON. SOME OF THESE VARIOUS
ELEMENTS.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE COMMITTEE
STAFFS PROPOSED BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD GIVE US THE
FLEXIBILITY TO DO SO WITHIN THE
FISCAL YEAR WE WOULD HAVE
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY.
BOTH TO SPEND THE MONEY AS
NEEDED IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S A SUCCESSFUL EFFORT
AND TO AUGMENT THAT AS NECESSARY
BEEN AND HOW WOULD THAT WOULD
UNDER COUNT HARMLESS.
IN THE KIND OF THE CENSUS.
PARDON SORRY IN ITEMS HELD THAT
IT WOULD UNDER COUNTERPART THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SEVEN UNDER COUNTY PLUMAS COULD
TAKE YOU MIGHT HAVE THE EXACT
NUMBER I THINK IT'S
APPROXIMATELY NINETEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS. A PER YEAR FOR A TEN
YEAR PERIOD THAT WOULD BE LOST
FOR UNDERCOUNTED INDIVIDUALS IN
FEDERAL FUNDING AS WELL VERSED
PER PERSON.
RIGHT PER PER UNDERFUNDED
INDIVIDUAL.
AND THERE'S ALSO THE POTENTIAL
FOR IMPLICATIONS FOR THE NUMBER
OF SEATS THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
SO AGAIN.
OPPOSITE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AGREES THAT THIS
EFFORT IS OF CRITICAL IMPORTANCE
AND WANTS TO SEE IT BE
SUCCESSFUL.
LL.
RUNNING AT.
THOMAS MISTER CHIU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ARE. LET ME ECHO
WHAT THE CHAIR SAID AND
SOMETHING WE ALL KNOW THIS MAY
BE ONE OF THE IF NOT THE MOST
IMPORTANT BUDGET DECISIONS THAT
WE MAKE AS FAR AS.
ARE OUR FUTURE BUDGET IN
STATE. AYE AND A I DO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE.
THE INITIAL PROPOSALS BY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
BUT WE ARE AN UNPRECEDENTED
TIMES AND WE HAVE A FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT UNFORTUNATE THIS
MOMENT IS NOT WORKING
PARTICULARLY WELL WITH US HERE.
OUGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
IS COUNTED.
WITH THE NEW POLICIES THAT ARE
PROPOSED IN THE AND THE LAWSUITS
THAT HAVE BEEN SUED. ARM
SO ONE ISSUE THAT I HAVEN'T AND
I'M I'M SURE YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT
THIS IS WELL I APPRECIATE THE
SOFT COMMITMENT ON WHAT THE
BUDGET WILL LOOK LIKE OVER THE
NEXT THREE YEARS. THERE'S BEEN
NO CERTAINTY AS TO WHAT.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
FUNDED WILL LOOK LIKE AND FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE.
CBO OUTREACH IS
POSSIBLY THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING WE COULD DO I CERTAINLY WE
CERTAINLY EXPERIENCE IN SAN
FRANCISCO IN TWO THOUSAND TEN.
ARE THE ONLY REASON OUR CENSUS
NUMBERS ARE WE. HAD SOME THE
MOST ACCURATE COUNTS IN THE
STATE WAS WE AS A CITY DEVOTED
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES TO TO
OUTREACH THROUGH CBO'S. AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT'S PART OF
THE PLAN BUT THERE'S NOT A
WILLINGNESS AT THIS TIME TO
COMMIT TO THAT. OF I WOULD LIKE
TO SUGGEST THAT WE COULD MAKE
THOSE COMMITMENTS IF THAT IS
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE IF THE
ISSUE IS. IS IS WHETHER.
DEAL WITH HAS A STAFFING TO
FIGURE THIS OUT YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY WE NEED TO GIVE
THEIR APARTMENT TIME TO DO THAT
BUT NOT HAVING A HARD COMMITMENT
ON WHAT THAT CBO OUT REACH IS
GONNA LOOK LIKE. A I THINK IS IS
IS CONCERNING MANY OF US AND AND
I'VE CERTAINLY HEARD ALREADY
JUST IN THE LAST TWELVE HOURS
CONCERNS AROUND STATE ON THIS
TOPIC SO. I WONDER IF YOU HAVE A
PERSPECTIVE ON ON THAT QUESTION.
CERTAINLY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL DOES INCLUDE TWELVE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS BILL
TEN FOR CBO OUTREACH.
VOTE CBO OUT REACHES LARGER
PORTION OF THIS TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS PLANNED ON A HOUSE BEEN
IN SOME PRIOR YEARS RECOGNIZING.
THE EFFECTIVENESS AND IMPORTANCE
OF HAVING LOCAL LEVEL OUTREACH
INVOLVED IN THIS EFFORT.
AND WHAT I WOULD SAY IS YOU CAN
APPRECIATE THE TWELFTH.
THE TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS SAN
FRANCISCO SPENT I BELIEVE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS
JUST ON ONE CITY AND THAT'S HOW
WE MADE SURE THAT ARE UNDER
COUNT A WAS NOT. DIDN'T INCREASE
AND I JUST OF THE QUICK MATH
LITERALLY AS YOU'RE SAYING THAT
A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A
DISTRICT IS EQUIVALENT OF.
YOU KNOW ONE OR TWO F. T. EASE I
DON'T THINK THAT'S A THAT I JUST
DON'T THINK THAT'S ADEQUATE.
NOT GIVEN WHAT'S AT STAKE IF IF
WE IF WE DON'T GET THIS RIGHT.
SO I JUST WANNA PUT THAT OUT
THERE IS A PERSPECTIVE ARE.
MY HOPE IS WE MIGHT BE ABLE HOLE
THIS OPEN FOR A FEW DAYS FOR
FURTHER DISCUSSION BUT IN
OBVIOUSLY.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION.
BROOKE DAVIS CHAIR.
YEAH THERE WAS A LOT OF NUMBER
SO AROUND I JUST WANNA GO BACK
TO.
.
WHAT WHAT HE SAID THE STATE WAS
TWO POINT SOMETHING MILLION IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN AND THEN
FOUNDATIONS CAME IN WITH TEN
MILLION SO TWELVE POINT
SOMETHING WAS THE TOTAL EFFORT
IN TWO THOUSAND TEN?
YES AND THEN THE U. S. CENSUS
BUREAU HAD A LOT OF THE AMERICAN
RECOVERY ACT DOLLARS SO THEY
ACTUALLY OF HIRED PARTNERSHIP
ASSISTANCE.
ACROSS THE BORDER MOTHER HOW
MUCH THAT WAS FROM THE FEDS I
THOUGHT THAT MY REMEMBER ON
DECEMBER TWENTY FOURTH TWO
THOUSAND NINE IT WAS LIKE THAT
HUNDRED MILLION ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND THEN THEY WENT OUT
AND HIRED SO I DON'T HAVE IT
POLKA DOWN TO THE STATE BUT FOR.
ABOUT TEN PERCENT OF THE
PROPAGANDA NEW BICU MET CHAIR
COMMENTS WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DO YOU HAVE A
DATE WILL WE KNOW WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S GOING TO DO
ON THIS.
SO.
I THINK THE LAST THING I SAW
WAS THAT IN OCTOBER OF THIS YEAR
THE CENSUS BUREAU'S OUR OUTREACH
INTEGRATED OUTREACH AND
COMMUNICATION PARTNERSHIP PLAN
WOULD BE IN FULL SWING THEY ARE
NOT SCHEDULED TO HIRE ANY
PARTNERSHIP SPECIALS WHICH ARE
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE. IN YOUR
DISTRICTS.
UNTIL OF LATE OCTOBER OF THIS
YEAR OKAY AND BASED OFF THE COM.
PLAN.
IT LOOKS LIKE THIRTY MILLION OF
THE FIFTY MILLION IS GONNA TV
AND AND NONPROFITS TO DO
OUTREACH IS THAT SIMILAR TO WHAT
YOU'VE DONE IN THE PAST.
SO IN A VERY VERY EFFECTIVE IT'S
HONESTLY TV IT'S A MULTI LINGUAL
AND THAT'S ACTUALLY MICRO
TARGETED SO IN THE CAN MEETINGS
THAT WERE DOING OUT YOUR
COMMUNITY. YOUR COMMITTEES WE'RE
MEETING WITH TRUSTED MESSENGERS
THERE TO IDENTIFY THOSE REALLY
ACTUAL LIKE ETHNIC MEDIA I MEAN
THAT IN TWO THOUSAND I DID A LOT
OF I WANNA TONGUE IN TALK SHOW
WITH. AROUND IN A LOT OF THE
ETHNIC MEDIA OUTLETS THAT ARE
KNOWN TO HAVE A NIELSEN RATING
THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT ARE MOST
EFFECTIVE AND SO PART OF OUR CAN
MEETINGS IS TO. UNDERSTAND FROM
THE COMMUNITY WHO THOSE WHO THE
TALENTS ARE YOU HAVE THE ABILITY
TO DO A LOT OF THE LEGWORK FIRST
WITH COME TAX RETURNS AND OTHER.
FISHING LICENSES AND THINGS
LIKE THAT CAN YOU GET A LOT OF
THE DATA UP FRONT AND THEN YOU.
PROBABLY HAVE AN ESTIMATE OF OUR
POPULATION AND YOU CAN YOU. MAKE
A PLANET JUST TARGET THAT.
SO THAT OF THE BROAD STATEWIDE
APPROACH GREAT SO THIS AGAIN THE
CENSUS BUREAU DOES A LOT OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE RECORD STUFF OUR
ROLE HERE THE STATE. ON WE DON'T
DO ANY OF THE COUNTING WERE JUST
DOING OUTREACH AND IN IN TWO
THOUSAND WE FOCUSED STRICTLY.
ARE ON THE HARD TO COUNT AREAS
WHICH THERE'S YOU KNOW OWN.
BASICALLY A DIFFERENT PARAMETERS
ABOUT WHAT MAKES AN AREA OR
POPULATION HARD TO COUNT AND I
CAN INTEGRATE THROUGH THAT IF
YOU WANT ME TO AND SO OUR
EFFORTS HERE THE STATE HAVE BEEN
ONLY REALLY FOCUSED ON THE
HARDEST COUNTING CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE THE U. S. CENSUS BUREAU
WILL DO KIND OF A A WIDE SWATH
OF ADVERTISING ANNOUNCING THIS
BILL DO THE MAJORITY OF THE THE
NO BIG YEAH FROM. CENSUS FOR OUR
OF.
.
TAX FILINGS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
THEY COLLECT THAT DATA IN THAT
IT'S IT'S OUR ROLE AS A STATE.
TO DO THE MARKETING
ESSENTIALLY TO ARCTIC
CALIFORNIANS I THINK WE'VE
LEARNED IN THE PAST THAT. THE
FOLKS IN IN DC WHEN IT COMES OUT
HERE THEY'RE NOT AS EFFECTIVE IN
ACTUALLY HAVING MESSAGES THAT
ARE CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE OR
THAT RESONATE WITH CALIFORNIANS.
WELL THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION PERSIA.
THANK YOU. GOING OPEN UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BRISK
THE CHALLENGE OUT OF IT WITH THE
BEST A PROJECT CALIFORNIA BUT
HERE REPRESENTING SENSES POLICY
ADVOCACY NETWORK. OF OVER STATE
OWNED IN OVER FIFTEEN
ORGANIZATIONS.
STATEWIDE REPRESENTING MANY
HARD TO COUNT COMMUNITIES. A
WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE THE
COMMUNITY.
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
ACKNOWLEDGING WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
SAYING SINCE DAY ONE THAT IT'S
GOING TO COST A LOT MORE THAN
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
APPROACH OUT REGION'S PLANNING
FOR CENSUS PURPOSES.
PARTICULARLY AS WE HAVE SHARED
IN OUR ANALYSIS AND LETTER THAT
IT'S GOING TO COST. HUNDRED
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS PLEASE
HUNDRED SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
PLUS FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. AND THAT IS
INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR'S TWELVE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS SO
IT'S NINE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR IN
ADDITION TO THE TWELVE POINT
FIVE.
AND HAVING SAID THAT WE ARE VERY
DISAPPOINTED WITH THE STAFF'S
RECOMMENDATION TO AUGMENT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSED
PROPOSAL BY NEARLY TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
LET ME BE CLEAR THAT THE STATE
DOESN'T ALLOCATE I REQUESTED
FUNDING THIS YEAR CPOS. WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO PLAN AND STAFF CENSUS
RELATED ACTIVITIES AS IT SHOULD.
UP ORGANIZATIONS NEED BUDGET A
CERTAINTY AND THIS
RECOMMENDATION DOESN'T PROVIDE
FOR THAT.
INFRASTRUCTURES ARE CREATED
BASED ON ADVOCATE FUNDING AND
NOT THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
I'M WE HAVE A LOT TO LOSE AT THE
STATE.
SEVEN SIX SEVEN SIX BILLION
DOLLARS. A ANNUALLY TO BE EXACT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AM WE ARE
NO LONGER TALKING ABOUT KEEPING
THE STATUS QUO OF RESPONSE RATES.
AS WE HAVE HAD IN THE PAST AND
SITE WE'RE ACTUALLY WORRY ABOUT
A LOWER RESPONSE RATE THAN EVER
BEFORE. AND THIS IS WHAT WE ARE
I'M HEARING FROM.
OR ON ALREADY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES.
A IN ORDER TO MITIGATE THIS
PROBLEM A STATE MUST INVEST
HEAVILY IN THIS YEAR'S.
STUMP CENSUS OUT WHICH
IMPLANTING IT HAS TO HAPPEN IN
THIS FISCAL YEAR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
HELLO MY NAME IS IN UNIX YES AND
I'M WITH THE COUNCIL ON AMERICAN
ISLAMIC RELATIONS WE ARE ALSO A
MEMBER OF SEE PAN. AND WE
REPRESENTS THE MUSLIM COMMUNITY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THERE
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION
MUSLIMS IN JUST TO GIVE UP A
PICTURE OF.
WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE IF WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH OUTREACH IN
FUNDING? RIGHT NOW MY COMMUNITY
IS VERY AFRAID OF A REGISTRY THE
VERY AFRAID OF THE CITIZENSHIP
QUESTION AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY
DOUBTING WHETHER OR NOT TO
PARTICIPATE. AND WE ARE THE ONLY
ORGANIZATION IN THE STATE THAT
ACTUALLY PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE
MOST INCREASE IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO LIKE INCREASE
FUNDING THE NIGHT FIVE MILLION.
AND ENSURE THAT OUR COMMITTEES
FEEL SAFE AND KNOW WHAT THEIR
RIGHTS ARE THANK YOU.
ANGELINA OF ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
ALSO NUMBER SEE PAN OUT IN
BEVERLY UP IN SUPPORT OF WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY
MENTIONED TRANSIT FOR THE
AUGMENTATION. CRITICALLY FOR CDL
FUNDING AND WE KNOW THAT EVEN
WITH DE CENSUS A QUICK QUESTION
AND CLEAN THE QUESTION MARK.
SINCE SHIP BUT ALSO WE ALSO KNOW
THAT IF IT'S OUR BEDS ARE DOING.
THINGS LIKE REJECTING
CALIFORNIA'S WAIVER FOR NON
CITIZEN ENUMERATORS RIGHT SO WE
NOTICE HIM BE A LOT OF
CHALLENGES BITTERNESS OR
SOMETHING SO YOU. I REQUEST FOR
FOR THE AUGMENTATION
THANK YOU.
ON A HAS A LEAD WITH UNITED WAYS
OF CALIFORNIA ECHOING THE
COMMENTS I'M ALREADY MADE.
AND THEN QUICKLY IN ADDITION
UNITED WAYS.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE AND.
THE SENSES BEING A SUCCESSFUL
REPRESENTATION OF ALL OF OUR
DEMOGRAPHICS.
AND YOU KNOW THE SUPPORT THAT
WOULD BE IN THIS PROPOSAL AS
WELL AS THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THIS REQUESTED FROM STAKEHOLDERS.
ENSURES THAT WORKED CAPABLE OF
DOING MATCH UP WELL THANK YOU
COULD YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHEN MEMBERS
MARTHA GROW REPRESENTING LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS APPRECIATE.
THE.
RECOMMENDATION BY.
THE BUDGET MAGIC BUDGET
CONSULTANT.
AT AND ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES.
INTEREST TO HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY OVER THE COURSE OF
THE YEAR TO INCREASE FUNDING.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS ONE HAS
ONE OF THE HIGHEST HARDEST WHOSE.
COUNT A COUNTIES AND IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WITH JUST THE NEW
CITIZENSHIP QUESTION WE WILL
HAVE AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION.
FOLKS THAT WE ARE TAKING A LOOK
AT HAVING TO REACH OUT OF AN
UNTESTED CITIZENSHIP QUESTION.
AND IN ADDITION THERE ARE ABOUT
ONE POINT SIX MILLION HOUSEHOLDS.
WHERE INDIVIDUALS WERE ABOUT
HALF OF THE INDIVIDUALS ARE NON
CITIZENS SO WE ARE REALLY
CONCERNED THAT IF WE DON'T HAVE
THE ADDITIONAL THREE POINT THREE
MILLION THAT WE ARE ASKING?
SO THAT MAKES IT TO TWELVE
MILLION THAT WE WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO EFFECTIVELY REACH OUT TO ALL
THOSE ADDITIONAL PEOPLE TO COUNT.
SO WE ARE I'M HOPING FOR THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
TOOK TWELVE MILLION FOR THIS
YEAR AND WILLING TO WORK WITH
YOU ON WHAT WE CAN DO TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CENTER CERAM SANTANA
REPRESENTING CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION WHEREIN THE
HEART OF CHINA TOWN ON THE
SEARCHES DISTRICT AND HE SO
ELOQUENTLY PUT. WHAT WE ARE
ASKING FOR WE DO APPRECIATE THE
AUGMENTATION AND WHAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IS A LINE ITEM? IN
THE AUGMENTATION FOR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS BECAUSE OF
THE VITAL THEIR ROLE THEY PLAY
AND FULFILL FOR TRUSTED
MESSENGERS GIVEN THE CITIZEN
CRUISE SHIP QUESTION AND THE
FEDERAL CLIMATES.
.
CBO'S WILL BE CRUCIAL TO THE
SECURING AN ACCURATE COUNT FOR
CALIFORNIA AND IT SHOULD BE
REFLECTED IN THE FUNDING AND
JUST ONE OTHER THING I DO WANT
TO THANK. ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR
LISTENING TO US REGARDING
LANGUAGE ACCESS AND CENSUS
OUTREACH INCLUDING.
THE SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE A IN THE IN THE APRIL
TWENTY FOURTH HEARING THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
BUT MISTER CHAIRMAN THE MEMBER
MICHAEL RATIGAN ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA
COUNTY TO EXPRESS OUR.
APPRECIATION FOR THE
AUGMENTATION RECOMMENDED BY
STAFF WITH THE.
WITH THE LANGUAGE AND JUST
INDICATE THAT WERE FULLY
PREPARED AND COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE STATE AND FACT
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SANTA CLARA HAS. COMMITTED THEM
A MILLION DOLLARS OF THEIR OWN
GENERAL FUND IN THIS EFFORT AND.
YOU KNOW WE APPRECIATE AS MUCH
AS YOU CAN UPON THEM. LIKES.
CHRISTOPHER GO THERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA GOOD POLICY
CENTER.
WE APPRECIATE THE SIMILES
AUGMENTATION FOR SINCE IT'S
OUTREACH.
HOWEVER WE'D LIKE TO SEE A A
LINE ITEM IN THE AUGMENTATION
SPECIFICALLY FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GENTLY BUT THEN ON BEHALF OF
MILD OF THE MEXICAN AMERICAN
LEGAL DEFENSE AND EDUCATIONAL
FUND ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE ON FOR ALL THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE AROUND. THE CENSUS
AND FORUM PROVIDING
DOCUMENTATION ON.
I'D LIKE TO LINE MY COMMENTS
WITH MY COLLEAGUES AS WELL AND
I'M. UP PAST THAT THERE IS A
LINE ITEM FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WE THINK THAT
MONEY IS REALLY CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THAT WE DO NOT HAVE AN
ACCOUNT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I LANDED ON WHAT THE WHITE AMONG
GROUP REPRESENTING NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA ALSO APPRECIATE THE
AUGMENTATION AND WILL DISTILLING
OUR COMMENTS.
WITH SEPIA.
I INGRAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIA LINE
IN MY COMMENTS WAS THE
PENICILLIN.
THANK YOU ORTEGA REFER THE
TESTIMONY OF ONE CLOSE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
WHERE THE WHOLE THIS ITEM OPEN?
SALUTE TO HOUSEKEEPING AND WE
WILL NOT MEET TOMORROW UNLESS
MEETINGS ON THURSDAY MAY TWENTY
FOURTH AT ONE THIRTY IN THE SAME
ROOM THAT CONCLUDES OUR HEARING